the following is a conversation with
Alexander Friedmann he's a professor at
Drexel University and the director of
the nihai and plasma Institute he's one
of the top plasma physicists and plasma
chemists in the world and most
importantly to me he's my dad
plasma by the way is not referring to
blood plasma in biology but to the
fourth state of matter in physics solid
liquid gas and plasma which is a gas of
charged particles that behaves in
fascinating ways plasma makes up the Sun
the Stars lightning plasma displays
fluorescent lamps and is the most common
state of matter in the universe this is
the 100th episode of this podcast there
were quite a few very big conversations
which were all options but I decided to
go back to where it all started for me
and to do a personal conversation with
my dad this was a difficult conversation
for me for many reasons but life is
short
perhaps we needed microphones to give us
a chance to say the things we never
would have said otherwise this is that
conversation this is also a chance to
briefly look back if you don't know I
stepped down from my full-time position
at MIT to pursue a dream of building a
start-up around AI systems that form
meaningful connections with human beings
I didn't have much money the videos I've
made and this podcast was a way to try
to pay for food and rent while taking on
the startup journey it also gave me a
chance to have conversations with people
who inspire me who make me think and to
share it with an amazing community
frankly I don't know what to do with the
idea that this thing has been listened
to thirty five million times I'm pretty
sure most of those are AI BOTS but if
you're one of the rare biological
systems listening to this thank you I
feel the love it gives me a lot of
strength in both this and the startup by
the way
some people asked my full very Russian
birth name is Alexei Alexei or Alyosha
or as my mom might say
Yoshioka but I've always enjoyed all my
friends and people close to me we'll
call me Lex or Lex in English a few
folks and companies donated money and
sponsored this podcast and they're the
reasons I'm here the best way you can
support me in this journey is to support
the sponsors please do I only do ads
here in the intro and not in the middle
for me as a fan mid-roll ads get in the
way of the conversation maybe I'm wrong
about that wouldn't be the first time
please click I'm a sponsor links in the
description sign up download buy
whatever they're selling that really is
the best way to support the journey I'm
on quick summary of the ads the Jordan
Harbinger show and magic spoon low-carb
keto friendly cereal go check out
Jordans show an apple podcast Spotify
you know where to look tell him I sent
you give him all the love in the world
and buy all of the magic spoon cereal
click the magic splint com / Lex link in
the description and use code elects a
checkout the more you buy for this
episode the more they will support this
podcast in the future you know what to
do
it's delicious and keto friendly so even
crazy people like me can enjoy more on
each in a minute this is the artificial
intelligence podcast I'm an AI
researcher and engineer first and
foremost but I see AI is much bigger
than anyone technical or scientific
field I see it as our journey to
understand and engineer the mind to
explore the nature of intelligence
consciousness human behavior the fabric
of the universe that gifted us the
triumphs and the tragedy of the human
condition without telling us except for
a few hints here and there about the
meaning of it all I will talk to
roboticists and philosophers physicists
and historians mathematicians and
astronauts and maybe even political
leaders always returning to the
technical which is home for me but also
not being afraid to venture out into the
messy human world I honestly don't know
how long I'll be doing this podcast life
is full of surprises
but for at least a short while I hope
you join me on this journey and thank
you for coming along this far this
conversation is supported by the Jordan
Harbinger show find it on Apple podcast
Spotify wherever you listen to podcast
or click the Jordan Harbinger comm slash
subscribe link in the description
I've been binging on it Jordan is
awesome he gets the best out of his
guests dives deep calls him out when
it's needed and makes the whole thing
fun to listen to his conversations with
Kobe Bryant and Neil deGrasse Tyson a
good examples of that one part I
remember real istening to is Neil
talking with Jordan about fountain pens
and how it brings you closer to the
words you're communicating outside of
interviews Jordan is also just inspiring
and pragmatic giving you solid no BS
life advice which is a nice complement
to what I ramble on about in this
podcast which can include things like
AGI quantum field theory or whether
neural networks can ever truly
understand language I'm not sure if any
of that gives you actionable life advice
so search and listen to the Jordan
Harbinger show an Apple podcast Spotify
give him some love tell him I sent you
this episode is supported by magic spoon
low-carb keto friendly delicious cereal
I've been in a mix as you might know of
keto and carnivore diet for a very long
time now that means eating very little
carbs I used to love cereal obviously
most cereals have crazy amounts of sugar
which is terrible for you so I quit
years ago but magic spoon is a totally
new thing zero sugar 11 grams of protein
and only three net grams of carbs it
tastes delicious
and honestly way too good to be true I
use it to celebrate a good training
session like the pushup
and pull-ups challenge up and ramping up
for it has four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry I tried all of
them they're all delicious but if you
know what's good for you you'll go with
cocoa my favorite flavor and the flavor
of Champions click the magic spoon
complex link in the description and news
code Lex at checkout for free shipping
and to let them know I sent you the more
you buy for this episode the more they
will support this podcast in the future
so buy all of their cereal it's
delicious and good for you you won't
regret it
and now here's my conversation with my
dad
Alexander Friedmann what to you is the
most beautiful idea in physics chemistry
or mathematics whoo let's go to that
place first before we go to the to Kiev
of the most beautiful in physics
chemistry I would say I would say
Einstein his ideas regarding stochastic
motion and Brownian motion I think it is
the most beautiful clear simple idea
because from these like statistics you
can prove existence of molecules believe
me or not it was I think it was his
first publication in 1905 with his first
wife it was significantly her idea
that's right there were collaborators
yes those five four four five papers he
published yeah I actually almost
everything which Einstein did it was
published the most important stuff they
were published in one here one nine on
five but the first idea was probably the
most elegant cases charge Brownian
motion and why you think it's beautiful
if you see that people at that time they
understand that if molecules if they
exist their motion is absolutely chaotic
boom-boom boom-boom-boom
what he proved the dust matter what size
of particles is there motionless similar
about the same so it is not necessary to
see molecules you can look at bigger
particles like if you smoke there is
particles and you can see like a
propagation of this smoke and from here
determine behavior of molecules and
that's actually relatively short very
elegant very clear and at that point
people they kept talking about molecules
but it was no proof because there is no
like a super electronic microscope to
see them so you know I'm saying yes
molecules they exist you said well I
mean can you show me there
so my Stein made it and booked and he
proved that a lot of people after these
public hearings that hmm probably
molecules really exists Einstein in 1905
so what do you like about that idea the
isn't olicity simplicity that's what it
is we proving something very very very
very very very complicated so if I ask
you for example you know molecules like
this can you prove it obviously like now
you would say ok I have a special
electronic microscope and I can we'll
take a look that small ok but when you
go back to beginning of 20th century
people they were laughing can you prove
sons you know you can no no no no take a
look it's something very simple very
very simple very very simple what do you
think it takes to do that kind of
thinking and come to those ideas and how
many times have you encountered those
kinds of ideas in your life have you had
any yeah yeah I would say that's
that's the whole beauty my feeling
that's the whole beauty of science it's
just you know people they say no no no
no it's so - it's impossible or and you
say no no wait take a look take a look
wait a second did they take a look just
think for five minutes if something is
very complicated you know kapitza Nobel
Prize all right like I work with him by
the way he used to say if it is
complicated it's probably wrong
ah well it was a lot of discussion
didn't kapitza inland ow because Landau
he he enjoyed to do something in a most
complicated way why his friend Kapisa he
was trying to do everything is an
absolutely simple way and they had all
these discussions because sometimes
capital he went to extremes and he used
to say well this is simple it means this
is right now he was like okay you means
that everything we simple is right i
mean like Fineman - yeah you like the
simple yes yes yes yes that's the whole
point to find this simplicity that's
that's the beauty of science that's a
beauty really there's a beautiful that's
something worse to do like at the risk
of going religious for a second
why do you think our universe allows for
such simplicity to be discovered that
such simplicity exists at all I can I
can tell you it is very similar to
Darwin's theory why I don't know why
animals they're this way not the other
way so it is actually competition take a
look about simplicity in beauty of
physics like you have two interacting
planets and the force is proportional to
one over R squared in this case they are
able to go in circles or
ellipses if there is another law they
are either falling or we're out so like
so if like our solar system exists so
just the interactions would be at 1 over
R squared that's it it's very
interesting about Isaac Newton and his
way of thinking that's also was the
super I would say genius is it weird to
you talking about noon that action a
distance for example this stuff I was
doing in elementary school which is
funny which without any knowledge of
physics but I I was doing physics
because of fighting throwing things how
better than that better than that we
played well it was 3rd 2nd 3rd gray so
it's in 1962 1963 so from one hand you
know key if that time so people they
were excited about worse obviously
always especially boys and also you know
we were way better than Americans
because you know we have first picnic
yeah
and Gagarin I remember how happy we were
when was good Irene a year yo I'm afraid
to make a mistake but I think it's 1961
or 1962 in 1961 1962 because what I
remember that I was in there either in
first grade or a second grade and it was
no bread delivery or not at that time
was a big problem because of Khrushchev
and the carriage of shortage of bread
shortage of all kinds of food no
potatoes no it was a mistake actually of
crucial because when he came to America
he saw that corners everywhere and he
decided yeah that if he put enough corn
in Russia
Russia will be way stronger from the
point of Agriculture than America
and but he overdid it as a result it was
a shortage of wheat hmm so that's why I
remember this moment
so just for kids lastly you remember so
yes so for kids what it is no no no no
each day yeah during the class you know
the special guy used to come and give a
small piece of white bread to each kid
white bread
yeah white bread and at the same time
hmm like a teacher and I always forgot
about this
Gagarin went to the space and kids they
even forgot about this the bread so
that's how big of a moment it is then
you're near I got bad take a look if you
are a boy you think about leasing out
space so like a 1/2 of voice they want
to be astronauts cosmonauts who we used
to say and the other half wanted to
design rockets so I was from this second
part so myself with friends we start
designing small rockets to fight second
grade second grade a second third second
third grade and we have been fighting
with these guys from a next-door house
because these idiots they used to use
only stones against us well and it was a
big fence between houses so jazz they
throw stones and we decided to make
rockets well and we made it and a
scientist was born engineer - yes it was
both science and engineering well let me
ask was at that moment or in general
when did you first fall in love with
science I would say science I think
clearly this fight with these beds the
rawest there are the kids with which
keep throwing stones from another side
of the fence and we start making rockets
what has he been a rocket as a fuel we
use a mixture of photographic films with
special chemicals yeah we consulted with
the boys from high school about some
details and we'd made it more or less
and then it was that stuff was actually
wrapped into the silver foil and in the
end we put like a match so with another
match we light it and this stuff was
going like sometimes ten meters yeah and
it was able to go to like 2 meters high
but very often it was mistakes because
like we were bad with stability so what
I try to calculate at this moment is
elect a trajectory hmm stability meaning
while it's in the air yeah control
problem yes yes control Sheikh so I try
to try to calculate what motion to
describe the moment where to point it
so where to point it to be sure that it
will go far enough
and it will go above the defense which
was maybe one meter eighty or something
like that so so what was most
interesting to you the calculations of
the math physics of calculating the
trajectory or the fact that you could
engineer build something that's based on
science in in the beginning in the
beginning in the beginning to be honest
I was happy to fight these idiots and I
have title defense yeah which what's
funny that we used to do that and and
they kept throwing stones which actually
you cannot prove anything but then in
the end of this period actually I fall
in love please
science what is science to you so there
in the inner period your eight-year-old
here one of teen events so not just to
throw a stone but just to make something
and just and take a look we made it so
the the the creation yeah and also
another important stuff when you are
doing this kind of stuff so your friends
they start thinking that you are not so
bad you know also it's a way to earn
respect
credit on their on the playground yeah
yeah we were not interested in girls you
know when you are like a second third
grade we just do we hated girls yeah but
it was very important to have respect
from yeah from well always follow along
right yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a
camaraderie and just feeling and secret
from parents and just to linger in it
because you brought it up Gagarin yeah
what are your thoughts
you know it's inspired on the American
side the Apollo missions inspired an
entire generation of scientists what was
your thought about Gagarin and the space
race and how that made you feel what
were role did it play in your life to be
honest the whole country had a huge
respect to Gagarin he was a nice person
very simple and he was hero because you
know to be first to go to the space yeah
knowing the percentage of success at the
time with dogs was way far from 100%
it's a big deal I would not say that it
inspired like a science science no it
did not
but making rockets it was just
interesting and about America we are way
better than America that's the way we
have been thinking I mean come on is
that yeah that's it was even not a
question yeah in America was saying the
same it's propaganda I was its
propaganda but keep in mind very very
important actually at that time in these
years Russia was way ahead yeah there is
it was no NASA that's right that's so
the fact that Russia is way ahead is
what motivated America to really step it
up it's from one hint but from another
hand for Russian kids of a second grader
and third grade mmm-hmm come on we did
not think about America that's like you
know
yeah that's millions miles away yeah
besides physics
you also have poetry in your blood so
what has been your relationship to
poetry music what role did you play in
your life poetry a lot but it is way
later then then Elementary School
actually like music wise you know like
Oh teenagers they're in love with music
and it's just exactly the same now and
twenty years ago and thirty years ago I
would say at that time at that time we
were all in love with one special group
which is Beatles and II and what was
extremely positive later its I was in
sixth grade fifth grade of the 60 64 65
66 and in Soviet Union Beatles they were
forbidden deliver not it was absolutely
strange but at the same time if
something is forbidden that's exactly
what you love most
so I remember that for my big successes
in science I was awarded who is going to
this best of the best
camps pioneer camps Arctic in Crimea and
over there it was international so I met
with I live together with group of
people from friends yeah because I was
the only one kind of speaking fluently
in French and we just made trade so we
gave whatever we used to have and we got
Beatles records little records and we go
yes that's the rebellion you're part of
it what about poetry what when did you
first
I mean you've written a lot of what poet
what maybe do you remember an early poem
you've written a bad one no I started
doing that late so it was I was in
seventh grade I think that's late Oh
writing poetry I thought and writing
poetry is a little bit related to when
boys they start looking at girls it was
a little bit different eyes we just
loved it somehow behind even not so much
even laughs even just you know this
imagination right like way far from
reality it's a it is romanticism were
you a serious poet or or funny poem
because you have a lot of humor example
it's later yeah but at that time as was
extremely serious Mir
extremely romantic which never ever
before after that is hardly management
yeah but it is kind of a little bit like
a childish romanticism or childish I
mean you know that bad but it was it's
interesting enough that first poetry was
actually almost immediately from my
purview very good it not like you know
you're doing something not good and then
better and and better and then better
mmm it's actually totally opposite best
stuff which I wrote it was like a south
great well around more like eight and
nice great and I wrote a lot at that
time why do you think you were so what
does it mean what good is good poetry
mean that means it's not cheesy it's
beautifully worded and he crafted it yes
and so ha where did that come from was
most people even great poets are
terrible at first so why why were you so
clever quickly as most people know you
as really fine clever no I mean would
words write very young words so you're
saying that was early on you already had
that yes I have no good answer it comes
from nowhere
yeah from but Michael Rockets just don't
know it woody poet wasn't recognized it
was it was actually to be honest no not
so much connection but in Russian
culture romanticism it is extremely
important element you know starting from
19th century Romanticism so yes it was
very popular so either you are writing
good poetry or bad poetry or you are an
artist you are like a you know painting
something so I have a lot of friends
they do painting do you remember poetry
do you remember a poem from that time
you've written by any chance yeah sure
I remember most of them by heart you
mind you mind reciting their in Russian
Russian is good as long as they're not
in French I have in French oh you wanna
me just do what do you think what what's
comfortable you know maybe I will read
one poor one point which I like most
from that period and I'm not sure that I
wrote something better after that well
it's a little bit cheesy however but not
much yeah it's like it's even not about
girls it's about music hmm but still
remain a romanticized kind of wisdoms
very strong medicine act was the result
of me reading a book particular janeyah
catimor
historia de chine another kappelmeister
organic wrestler
actually the story of a cat who found
the book or like a notebook but the
notebook of people he starts reading
about that and analyzing their life so
the life of people through eyes of a
very very smart cat so then I can read
it in Russian right and in the spoiler
if you want please I'll be doing ok
IRA's vanities would open on Krishna hip
a socially to Roseville s Kapellmeister
your gum Chrysler booted placket see
when you love us
the billion so he Buddhist needs a
voyage Kafka Livadia and a woman noticed
me so detail I mean like the one who
died in the mirror of cellist a perky
notice Beach Smoke shown Kino numerous
she regrets what Tolkien is smoke his
rival's castaway piles even Rock a
Christian ray I'll eat alone a zookeeper
a religion newest rupee Charla's economy
lips creepy a leash Malibu zoo mashhad
or Goose Creek Astley our yearly calico
Nadine Don Dona Torino Shira yalla Paris
Smith not mere insignia burry it
acoustikats layaway piles police garage
new lazuli raspberry this would open on
Christmas Eve associated Roswell s
kapellmeister again crazier PD plackets
Union
Lois Wow that's good and it's like I
would say that whatever I did later it
was however you do here so someone's
great so this eight eight great it's
very 15 that is that's very good yeah
and it's a that's a romanticism you know
I was a little bit of like it too much
it's musically cheesiness a little bit I
would say but very strong
so let's go let's go okay to Kiev okay
let's go to Kiev you were born and
raised in Kiev just like yes the guys
with the rocks and the Rockets but that
was the
guys you know I get word he got that you
can hold a grudge
what are some memories of your dad and
mom that stand out and hmm okay yeah
what we do well let's drink in Japanese
so yeah what are we drinking Japanese
whiskey in Japanese whiskey they call it
from the barrel or not sponsored by NECA
whiskey but in the whiskey yeah we do
not but they're doing a very very good
job
yeah and they are in Sapporo it's
Hokkaido north of Japan so they are
doing good beer which is superb
they good very good whiskey and a lot of
red caviar and make sure that's it
did you ever think when you were that
shortage of bread and you're doing the
rocket that you'll be sitting here in
America few years later drinking
Japanese whiskey talking about caviar
did you even know what caviar was oh no
no obviously because scaler it was for
holidays a little bit and it was
distributed it's not like you're going
buy it but you got it a little bit like
a small can
so we all of us we knew that and just it
was very popular and well let me just
actually ask that question how did you
imagine what where you would be 50 years
from then I think how did you think
about your future actually like in about
eight grades nine grades I was very very
very very very very good in physics
mathematics and chemistry so I was
actually in this system of like an
Olympiad so-called competition
I was absolutely number one in Ukraine
twice and absolute number two in Soviet
Union also twice this is physics
competition or mathematics okay it was
physics so therefore people who don't
know maybe you can explain I mean this
is still goes on to this day these are
very intense competitions I don't know
if they're that popular in the United
States probably because the United
States folks don't do is great but I
there it is extremely popular but not in
physics what is going on in this country
I was very much impressed it's a very
serious and very tough competition in
mathematics in math that's right in
physics class and biology last so you
already know new somewhat in eighth
grade that you're very good and yes wait
a minute you said chemistry - yes of
chemistry - physics chemistry and
competed you won in Ukraine and I was
number two in Soviet Union it was twice
now very interesting that in Soviet unit
was a rule you supposed to choose so you
can participate in this competition in
physics mathematics and chemistry
and all three of them up to the level of
championship of the region of the big
city in my cases was Kiev but then to go
to competition in Ukraine you have to
choose you can go to only to one so I
want physics and chemistry and
mathematics in Kiev then I choose
physics and I was going to Ukrainian now
if you win in Ukraine so a couple of
people from the whole Ukraine goes to
this championship of Soviet Union that's
an incredible accomplishment whether
using it was I mean you basically you
peaked in terms of physics and poetry at
age 14 that's a big difference you know
in physics I was really on top of the
Soviet Union which is a huge country in
poetry it was just but no I'm not a
professional you know and you can't
compete in poetry way
yeah well by the way over there gold
medal from high school so what you call
here a valedictorian which is hard to do
I would say here it's also very the
announcing independent school but in
Kiev it was an interesting situation
because oh you have to the most
difficult was actually not physics
mathematics and it was writing but
because it was writing not on the
computer without spellcheck it just and
you have to write hard to when you let
me see let me hear no 12 12 pages as
minimum of an essay and it's supposed to
be zero mistakes
and the Russian language is not the
easiest one and when you say mistakes I
mean this is what makes the grammar real
wrong mistake it's not just its grammar
it's writing mistakes - oh no I wouldn't
mean writing mistake I just incorrect
use of word or something can you cross
stuff out no right this is the you can't
make a mistake in the actual writing
process you're writing with a pen
yeah and immersive you're not supposed
to make any direction and you're not
allowed to cross the lines and that's
its perfection in song and all the
victory is for me and it's silly but me
what do you think about that is it what
what do you think about that strictness
because it it it's easy to criticize
from a distance but there's something
powerful about it yes there is it you
know what counter is more powerful from
this point of view is Japan is pest
retinas
I was so much impressed with their kids
what they keep saying that in Japan for
kids
it does matter it's a holiday or the
weekend or whatever each day you
supposed to train with these Japanese
characters because it's not it's just
impossible just to remember it so they
are there working too hard but as a
result they can say for them koala t
because quality means no mistakes
alright that's very interesting point
what does mean quality it means no miss
isn't perfectionism
perfectionism creates this kind of
whiskey yeah which this is what perfect
tastes like it's interesting I mean it
forces you to take this education
seriously everything seriously like this
yeah this craftsmanship it did cross me
seriously yes yes yes and you know I I
mentioned to you this exam this exam in
in Russian I say but it was something
which was worse than that
yeah because because it was Kiev we
supposed to take two essays one in
Russian language and also in Ukrainian
language so think for a second it's a
it's not your native language and he's
supposed to also write this at least 12
pages without with zero mistakes and
without any possibility to make any it
should be perfect as a result was funny
that I speak Ukrainian not bad at all
because of this I wouldn't say that's a
good idea but it's it's kind of Russian
Russian version of of a Japanese story
but yeah you know there's a lot of
interesting other strict things I get to
memorize poetry here to memorize things
which I mean that's a really interesting
exercise oh that's what probably you
remember yeah though it still was there
when I was there yeah yeah like I used
to know at least thousand poems by heart
by heart and you still remember many of
your own by heart yeah it's by the way
helps this mathematics how good memory
just memory okay so you said you already
knew I mean it's an incredible
incredible accomplishment to be at that
level in physics at that young age so
what did you think about the future
returning to the original question where
do you think that would take you this
fascination and this skill with physics
did you imagine hiding a professor did
you imagine being Hine Stein
you know kids in high school I mean at
least between us and I was like already
in in high school it was like special
high school in physics and mathematics
we were all like not only dreaming but
being sure we can do that we can be best
of the best in the world and and it was
very popular subject at that time if you
are like the best thing in physics it's
the way more you are way more popular
than a guy who is the best in basketball
yes interesting I mean that's why do you
think that isn't a Soviet Union that it
was so respected it's so admired when
you were great at science it was
propaganda so was the state created
there yes so and it was good do you
think we'll ever see that in America
without authoritarian in a democracy
because in America Brad Pitt and Michael
Jordan are the superstars and scientists
most people don't know a single
scientist except Einstein in America
well I would say my feeling it should
happen in America it should happen to
two boys and girls in America it should
be sure it meaning like that's a good
thing or is everything anyway it is very
important because if if kids in America
they are just not so much good in
sciences sooner or later we will lose
competition to to countries where
science is very much high prestige
example today unfortunately not Russian
the best example today is probably chain
I I've been there I saw their high
schools we have to be very careful with
that so my feeling that that it should
be done because in America university
education is way stronger than in Russia
and they're way stronger than in Europe
but high school education in America is
not so so strong well yeah it's
difficult to understand why but why what
do you think the universities are so
strong in America why do you think the
most Nobel prizes are from America why
do you think science is so good even
though scientists were never really
worshipped in America because in Russia
it was always a problem so the strongest
you know that people students kids they
they're they are very hard workers when
they are in high school because after
that there is a very strong competition
to get to a good university very very
very challenging the same in China so
you have to be very good to enter very
good University so kids they work like
crazy to do that also boys they knew
that they have take a look you have one
chance in most of cases with exception
of couple of universities have only one
chance to go to one University to try
yourself
if you make it you become a student if
not you go to the army for three years
so you it's very interesting it's a very
psychologically interesting situation
because what is going on you have to
make a decision by yourself are you
strong enough to go to the best place
because it's only one place you can go
now they start changing this system but
in 1960 seventies eighties nineties it
was the case so just another cost
because the feeling once you're choosing
you don't get in course not money-wise
but real cost
if you are a boy if you if you just
overestimate yourself mm-hmm is that
when you got that line in your hair that
that period so for people who don't know
my dad's hair now is white but he used
to have the sexy stripe down the middle
for many decades yeah yeah yeah 10 20 30
a lot of my pictures I have this right
now anymore nothing he wants a good look
now
so anyway is that when you got a
distress that's when you were oh no the
stress was it was a real stress what
happened well that's that's a bad story
I told you that in when I was a
finishing high school as it turns great
the time I became a champion of Ukraine
number one and second in Soviet Union
which was a very very big deal after
that five kids on six no five five kids
from Soviet Union was supposed to go to
international competition and this
international competition was the same
dates as you know exams to enter the
university so if you are a champ if you
are like in five best five best kids in
physics five best kids in mathematics
five best kissin whatever chemistry they
were able to skip these final exams
which means to skip this essay in
language one languages say another
language and you skip all exams but
instead of that you prepare to
international competition so because I
was number two I was clearly the team so
I was not supposed to go to this stupid
exams
and but well but it was a telephone call
of our leader from Moscow he said that
like it's like one week before but
unfortunately you have to be replaced
with another guy because they are unable
to give you a visa oh and that was
actually yeah that was a stress it was
it was a very big stress and at that
point like people including those from
America and scientists motion they came
to me and they asked me you know to make
speech and just to say something and to
do something and they talked to my dad
to your grandfather
hi he spoke with people from KGB because
he was like the guy had time and and he
came to me and said okay you do whatever
you want because it's your life you make
a decision but they told me that if you
forgot about what happened you have gold
medal which is over there you pass all
exams and you will have a well five in
Russian a highest grade whatever you do
it will be a yeah and then you go to any
university you want and you'll be
accepted this is KGB talking those kinds
of folks yeah and I hesitate it and I
said well yeah I agree I am I I will not
fight against the system so can you
explain a little bit does you being
Jewish have anything to do with it
absolutely it's 100% okay so because it
was actually it was a 1970 and in this
moment it was very significant
actually push the immigration for Jewish
people to Israel and to America and they
they were afraid always and they just
give all these awards to the to the guy
and he will say okay guys goodbye I just
decided to go to whatever to America or
to Germany or whatever or to Israel
keeping that in mind just in case they
prefer not to give Iza and at that time
interesting enough is KGB so they do not
give visa and they do not give any
explanation why right just you cannot do
that however however they say he's a
good guy and if he accepts that will do
everything for him
don't worry it's also risk because you
never know they can but I don't know
maybe maybe I am so smart but actually
without special preparation I went to
these super exams and I got a you did
well how did well so and that's the
reason of this stripe which appeared in
very short bundes it was a source of
stress but I'm not exactly understanding
the depth of the stress it was very cg /
- ways to make I mean it doesn't feel
like there's a choice he just had
actually when already I made a decision
I was already with the store okay so the
decision process was because I was it's
like you know I was falling from a limp
or whatever like because I I was feeling
that everything is like I'm best of the
best in the world whatever and boots
they actually put me on my place you
know
it was difficult moment but but then I
was accepted and it wasn't you know
immediately celebration because you know
I got this gold medal which is a big
deal in Soviet Union the gold represents
being a valedictorian well it's very
right
so did you experience anti-semitism
leading up to that moment in your life
did you feel that you were what you mean
to feel that you were Jewish did you
experience life as a as a Ukrainian Jew
or simply as a Ukrainian well for the
listener that is uncomfortable talk
likes to avoid uncomfortable
conversations so I have to force them
into uncomfortable conversations okay oh
well it's not only me just like all our
generation in at that time in Ukraine in
Ukraine Ukraine at that time it was not
the same as Ukraine today so level of
anti-semitism was way higher in Ukraine
than in other places in other soviet
republics all right why is that
is there any historical yes reason
phalanges well it was actually
historical significantly historical
reason starting from bogdan Olinsky so
at some point a couple of hundred years
before that Jews they supported polish
people and it was against Russia against
the grain so just a level of
anti-semitism was very high in this kind
of countries also this area was inside
of Pale of Settlement which was a lot of
Jews a lot of Jews a lot of problem with
Jews in Moscow it was forbidden for Jews
to leave so no no Jews no problems so
when I actually moved from Kiev to
Moscow it is like a day and night so
Moscow it was beautiful I mean I did not
feel well I feel felt but not
my charity in Ukraine always I felt that
I am Jewish but from another hand you
remember all these kids from our yard
like a stone that's that they're opposed
both groups a were Jewish yeah
so what I'm trying to say that Jews they
lived actually together so from that
point of view you know it's less it's a
huge anti-semitism but but they are
somewhere you're somewhat isolated from
it because because it's like a Jewish
gigantic together I mean they juice it
was its historical ghetto yeah okay
let's let's jump back okay we were
saying that you were born and raised in
Kiev what what are your favorite or
maybe most representative memories of
your dad and mom from the earlier years
well it was a beautiful family you're
the only chance you're just i was only
charged one yes and my father he was a
hero of World War two and he was
actually always with a stick because you
know he was like a cane yeah cane right
he was heavily wounded even in the war
and he operated the the gun the machine
gun he's a goner very complicated
situations
huh so he was risking his life enormous
Lee and the only reason he survived
because he was heavily wounded so just
it was the end of the war for him and
you know and as a boy you know for me he
was eerie and he was a real hero he was
like you know it's not it's very
different for me he's like a big hand
you know like always he was not drinking
Japanese whiskey he was drinking only
one thing what yeah he remember like we
had somewhere this yeah we'll get to the
bar yeah but what I'm trying to say that
it's a different personality
and he just from this Jewish boy he
became an associate minister of
construction of Ukraine which was a very
big deal so he was like this he's very
much different from me I'm like a little
bit like a software personality my like
my mother but he was a very tough guy
yeah were you afraid of him hmm
what does mean to be afraid he loved me
but he was a person like you know very
strong personality so yes well if I did
something wrong how you remember the
story no no I mean these idiots from
another from the yeah in this rockets so
yes I was afraid of my father so I had
huge respect and my mother she was like
a nice Jewish mother and it well let me
kind of ask a hard question to you've
lost your dad a few years ago yeah what
did it feel like when you learned that
he died what went through your head
what memories well like you know losing
your parents it's excluding your parents
so I would say what I can say it's a
losing paradin and my father it was a
whole generation you know it's just like
and you know the feeling you have that
now you are the man that's interesting
whether the killing is now it's my
trying to be great now just I have to do
something now just because when you have
your parents you always have this
feeling that there is something behind
you just in case yeah and my father he
was very very very strong personality
just this interesting story that during
this
mmm Jews persecution in 1952 by Stalin
when it was so-called a fair of doctors
or whatever how to say in English
deliberately when Jewish people were
actually said just their doctors and
okay most of nocturnal were Jewish
Wesley so they used to say that they
actually kill half of the government or
whatever as a doctors it was absolutely
lie it just says nothing with reality
and Jews they were prepared actually to
be moved from all over so it Union to be
a began to like a close to Chinese
border on a more River like oh it's
already they try to move them closer to
Japan to Japan is whiskey so like in
camps know what just just just just kind
of move them straight to to the so
called the Jewish published Jewish
region or whatever but it's like it was
nothing there yeah and if you move like
this kind of group of people I was about
three million Jews not forget you know
at least half will die just during this
moving so it was nice and you're
preventing them from having a future
yeah so at that time you know people
they kept start kept talking about the
same stupid stuff that Jews a drink
blood of babies of Christian babies yeah
and and that's what my father used to
say that his friends and it's like you
know it's like a meeting and you know
people are asking have you seen
something have you seen him like a
drinking blood or something like that
and he said that he was absolutely in
products to his friends and all of them
they mostly I mean they are or either
leaving the room just not to participate
in this stupidity war they say we
haven't seen but who knows if people
they write in newspapers is a very
strong propaganda
so they he lost he was a associate
director of this manufacturing plant and
they say that he's supposed to leave
because because this whole propaganda
he's a Jew and choose a drink in the
blood of Christian baby
maybe maybe who knows yes maybe it's
enough there's no evidence that they're
not yes right so so he is not going to
prison but he is not going to work in
our enterprise so he said okay I am like
a social director and I want to be a
worker a simplest worker but because I
love my plants he said no so actually he
left it was what was that memory
standout for you why because it was it
was 1952 and I was born in 1953 so just
so what was happening that he was
without job for one year because nobody
wanted to to take him before Stalin died
in 1953 it was home and when I was born
so my mother she worked to support the
whole family and we lived in a small
room 14 square meters it was my
grandmother grandfather father mother
and me so the I mean the it's kind of it
was a big impact on and then Stalin died
and everything become way better is and
in terms of anti-semitism as well you
see there is a good movie by the way
made here in America a Russian Jews part
1 and Jews / - lysandros part 3 I think
it's a Youtube version yeah so what is
that
it was almost no anti-semitism before
World War 2 right it was very strong
anti-semitism after the end of the World
War 2
and in 1945 and death of Stalin in 1953
in 1953 serration become better but not
as good way not as good as in the
nineteen thirties
why was there anti-semitism after the
war the Second World War
it seems the idea hearted Russia sorry
to interrupt
how did Russians in your memory think
about the the the cruelty of the
Holocaust because there's so much pride
about Russia winning the war of being
the you know to getting to Berlin isn't
how do you think about the people that
were tortured well well I read it very
strong very strong propaganda propaganda
very strong propaganda so what happened
that okay what actually happened that in
the end of okay before World War two
yeah before world war ii actually jewish
people they just they forgot that
they're Jews it was mmm I mean they were
all Soviet like a little bit first
Soviet first on way way first I mean it
was before work in the end of the war
Jewish people they create a lot of
special organizations and because of
Holocaust they had significant support
of United States of America and Western
countries but most United States of
America and Jewish people in the end of
over tool they start thinking that it's
like my story with this when I graduated
from high school
so they started believing that they are
big guys you know because I have so much
support from the United States and it's
also and and on top of that like a
cherry it was a creation of Israel
and right I was around and so and I did
49 there's a kind of a push that Jews
are no longer Soviets they their
homeland is yes and and Jews a felt like
a initially very nice but they overdid
it
so bottom line it was a and also don't
not to forget about Hitler so as a
result level of anti-semitism in from
1945 to 1953 was growing significantly
then it was a little bit better but
actually significant improvement starts
happening only in 1960s not earlier than
that so can you talk a little bit more
about your dad's journey in World War 2
I mean there's I remember a bunch of
stories but you know just for people
interested you know is World War two is
at the core of our family in a sense so
can you just linger and maybe if you
have memories about it his impact how
did he get injured was his relationships
with you know violence with death was
bullets flying everywhere
yeah my father he was born in 1923
so in night and we're in Minsk in Minsk
which is now with Russia and he was born
in October so when world war started he
was 17 and it was forbidden to go to
army if you are younger than 18 so
together with his friends they may
change in a spurt
they just change their year from they
made themselves one year older just to
be accepted to the army and interesting
enough that like the way I understand at
least these people who organized like a
army they understand they saw that this
boys are younger but they let go he
wanted to go what he wanted to go you
know there's so many stories and you
know more in America where there's
there's a lot of people brave people who
found ways to not go yeah here it's
absolutely opposite
it's absolutely opposite because most
well not not everybody over this one but
majority propaganda was extremely strong
so protecting your father and mother one
its he was to die for your country yes
yes yes
so to die for your country it was kind
of like an honor
yeah that's and also they were sure
that's Red Army his hungry trans
stronger than this Germans yeah so and
they thought that okay we'll go there so
couple of months and we are winners but
in one way or another but they were
wanted to go especially when you know
you're not like a very rich guy you know
so he went to the army and it was like a
couple of months special preparation to
become
like a lowest level of officers
so junior latent or whatever it is in
this country and he became like this
low-level officer and he starts actually
I near Moscow and just start going back
and back and back and back and and
that's it and he was with this machine
gun big one and you know the change of
like it was very fast so people they
were killed very very very fast actually
people that were operating machine guns
yeah
ah very very fast because just finish
the changeover
change so he became division commander
reasonably fast decision region that's
one way to move up on everybody's dying
yeah yeah yeah yeah and what he kept
saying
I think even to you because he just it
was like he kept saying that for some
reason he was absolutely sure that every
year he saw that like everybody else had
killed and he's not so he was kind of
sure that something is protecting him
he's invincible and yes he's invincible
he he and I wasn't writing and he was
very strong actually very very very
strong
like by the way physically and mentally
physically and mentally so kind of like
helix I mean he is like because this
dude would not like myself but he is
very
physically strong and mentally protected
like I don't know what best way to say
that he's he was sure in himself and he
was sure that there's a confidence is
that yeah yeah yeah no no no it's not
it's a confidence it's a constant a
little bit like a kind of like a
religious but here he he did not believe
to the gap through the first place come
but he believed in what he was to say in
his star services there is a star which
protects him and I be right and he might
be right
he survived war he got he survived war
because after like for no like five or
six months he was heavily wounded which
was very good yeah actually because
that's right he's right in the leg in
the leg yeah so he was like and he had a
lot of this horse
do you remember what about the people in
general you know 20 million plus Soviet
people died what impact do you remember
what impact the war had on the people is
enormous enormous that's why for 20
million it is a lot and it's a need I
half of them were just civilians because
Stalin he just operated this war without
counting people yeah but do you think it
had powerful creative impact in terms of
music art literature the science a sad
thing about war all all of the above
science mostly all of the above it
because even before war science was very
much pushed up but after the war
scientists they were considered like the
key people in the world especially
military scientist
I don't think I've ever asked you this I
haven't asked you most of the things I'm
asking but you're Jewish Hitler killed a
lot of Jews how did you feel about the
Holocaust I don't think we've actually
really talked about is it just an
intellectual tragedy to you or did it
ever feel I know I but what do you think
about human nature after that who is he
that I have parents and my parents they
have parents which my grandparents and
they're my great-grandparents so all of
those all of those without exception
were killed in Holocaust zero died with
their own death natural death all of
them they were killed because they were
like already a little bit older like I
am now and they were sure that Germans
they will not touch them come on just do
something to old people itself strange
and all of them without exception all of
know they were killed so it is you know
like initially in my life I just it was
like a really hatred with respect to
Germans in general which only later I
mean it was clear that it's not it's not
say it's not German in Germany but
that's but it was very serious feelings
about that so hatred but so as you as
you grew grew up did it
are you hopeful about whether people are
good or evil and did that have a impact
on you know the fact that you can see so
much evil you can become cynical
the way you still did you is there still
an optimistic positive person inside you
yeah there is
I am optimistic myself I am optimistic
so just like the point is that like I
was when I just start growing up even
even in high school level of
anti-semitism was like a way lower and
in general I felt myself always way more
Soviet then I was a Russian Ukrainian or
Jewish sure
so what what was your relationship of
the Soviet Union we'll talk about coming
to America but what was your feeling so
you're proud for it for many years I was
very proud I was very proud of this
style of life where science is really
popular where people they're working not
for money but people are working for
form to make something interesting to
make something good it's the place where
if you if you if you're good you are
rewarded and that was a healing it was
propaganda obviously so for like when I
was in high school middle school high
school and I would say in school I was
feeling that I'm extremely proud
so again then it was this shock change
and then a lot of friends I started
going to Israel or America so just
everything start changing
every since I've chased after Stalin
after though it's you know it's wait so
it's already I'm talking about like
1970s in the 70s yeah
the 1970s already like people they
against our feeling that they're Jewish
because of significant immigration to
America and Israel okay say you were in
Kiev through high school mmm-hmm so
let's look to your next chapter of your
life and can you tell me what is fist
yeah since as its I don't even know what
the full in English name is Moscow
Institute of Physics and technology and
what is it in Russian the full name
Moskovsky facility hsk Institute em fat
I um it's it smells like MIT police yeah
yeah yeah my PT yes yeah yeah it is am i
P TSD kind of it's a kind of a mighty I
don't know it's maybe a little more like
a Caltech oh no I was there an
engineering component it's very small
right I mean what was it was the size of
a cultic and it was very much focused on
science and military science and now
sorry to interrupt no this was in Moscow
yeah and so you came from Kiev the
Moscow Moscow so how did you get into DC
so what yeah so you said this yeah cause
this stuff is focused on science
military science this is like the I saw
on the internet this description of
maybe you can talk to it math and
physics education at MIT the number of
hours I think or compared to fist yeah
and they were I mean they were making
first of all the CCF education is
shorter and covers a like an order of
magnitude more material yes exactly
what can you explain what what that
experience is like what the with their
idea of the kind of holiday they're
putting you through is what the
philosophy but that is what I've been
looking for because you know don't
forget that well you're coming to the
place and you feel yourself best in the
world and when you meet people from you
know outside you're like a you're like a
different personality you are from mipt
you are from from Castilla so it was a
lot of songs a lot of it was a theory
and we were so much proud that number of
credit hours
it was incredibly we work from 9:00 to
5:00 each day you can from 9:00 to 5:00
it is eight hours so it's eight hours of
classes how many days a week six days a
week so you can count and it's and the
level was and your requirements they're
very very very very strong and it is
math physics chemistry what was the
range of subjects important twice
importantly like anyway when you enter
like a you start with very high level
mathematics physics and chemistry
actually and why did you want to call
this yeah so it's basically because you
thought you were one of the best people
in the world at math and physics yeah so
this is the place to go and chemistry
yes in chemistry and that's that's
that's the way to go by the way when I
came to Moscow I hesitated for about one
day because I also I was in love with
mathematics and mathematics meant like a
freedom so they had less classes they
were more open for
like creative thinking well this jacket
was like a what's the best word to say
what they do like in sports like um make
like something extremely hard for you
later
what's the name how you say for military
for military from either and USA boot
camp yeah when I said boot camp but yeah
this is really intense so innocence of
weeding out week yes and that was going
on actually so the significant number of
students they were actually living after
the first semester yeah it was extremely
challenging also keep in mind that it
was about okay usually group it was like
a twenty five people thirty and usually
one girl so it is like a whatever they
three percent girls ninety seven boys
it's also create very special atmosphere
well it's maybe just two before before
we get into the special atmosphere
what was your journey to fish yeah like
so I think I read a book a love and math
by ad Frankel also Russian I think he
mentions he stuck in there and he's also
Jewish and he said that there's a lot of
anti-semitism that that there's a bunch
of schools that you weren't I mean it
was either explicitly or implicitly no
Jews allowed yeah well so did you
so what was the process of getting into
this place and how much anti-semitism
was there one in that picture at that
period it was 1970 it was a clear
well it's anti-semitism yes absolutely
what but what I mean that it was like a
for Jews it was really difficult to get
into the universities very simple but in
most of universities the rule was kind
of hidden so just it was like a Jewish
boy and not Jewish boy and they were
going to the same exam and the professor
gives like a G or C for the Jewish guy
and like B or a for for a not Jewish guy
if their level is the same it was just
in most of places but Moscow means the
physics and technology it was very
different exams they were absolutely
honest however however they count grades
it was two exams in physics and two
exams in mathematics oral mathematics
great mathematics or physics written
discs a b c g and a is 5 B is 4G 3G is 2
and if you're Jewish an exam they were
very very very very very very tough yeah
the world I hear all of them and that
was written and oral they were extremely
challenged but equally for doesn't
matter you are Jewish or not Jewish
where iam now if you are Jewish you have
to have to to go through that after have
either 19 or 20 which means yeah which
means it should be a a a a or
one day well if you are not Jewish 17 is
absolutely ok 16
some people 15 some people so it was
made clear and this beside that is
completely fair it was you know it was
from some point of view it was good
because it is not like a cheating it was
like a clear rule let's do it all so it
was very interesting that after exams it
was a special interview and was
interviewers
with really high level scientists it was
like it two or three famous famous
famous scientists and one or two KGB
people and and they just you know
managed this operation it is impossible
to discuss so they say yes you are
accepted great Cory they say no you're
not
why that's our decision so what was your
favorite subject topic ideas that you
fell in love with in in the first few
years of this year it was general
physics because we had absolutely
beautiful a lecture and a half his books
even now I have over there he wrote like
a lot of books solution see booking yeah
and he was very interesting personality
I wasn't laughed with him for I would
say two years no more than that because
his idea was you have to present physics
absolutely without calculus so it should
be no derivatives and no integration
how's how's that possible just do you do
physics you can most you say physics you
mean like mechanics oh no no no no no
physics means physics it's mechanics
it's a thermal sciences its electricity
optics and nuclear physics everything
MODOK ever was that okay the only thing
he didn't attach it was no quantum
mechanics was quantum mechanics in the
air back then yeah obvious but not for
this gentleman
not for this professor he was not so
much he was no famous scientist he was a
famous teacher and then only then I just
you know jump to the world of
theoretical physics
and and chemistry so and that the next
step in my life is just jumping into
theoretical physics and what what branch
of theoretical physics were you
interested in so I've never actually
heard you talk much about the world is
the big like general relativity so
looking out into the Stars you were more
interested in like what physics
phenomena were you interested in now or
that that so at that time at that time
after this two years with civilian I
just changed completely to absolutely
opposite approach to purely theoretical
physics and at that time the most
popular it was the so-called run down
minimum so run down ten books and they
are believe me they are Wow
so they are so hard yeah they are just
for some reasons areas you know hardest
of the hardest like very challenging
very difficult and it's the boy is so
just they say if you want to show
yourself you have to go to the so-called
endowment we should have to go through
ten exams actually eleven because the
first one is was mathematics and then
whatever physics one physics to physics
ten and you know it was a challenge it
was very difficult I went through that
just actually I don't know just to prove
yeah that I can do that to be honest I
did not in the end at least I hate that
because it was mm not so much
it is not fine one you know it is just
something opposite to that do the
opposite yeah yeah but it's it's painful
almost for the sake of being painful yes
it's like it's like you are doing the
martial arts yeah that's
just to show you yourself that you can
do that yeah so that's what I did and
then when I was actually I was keep
doing that but in the middle it was the
first time when I came to Kolkata means
to the photonic energy so speaking of
which what is the couch out of Institute
of atomic energy and who was your so I
feel like in VCF there's an advisor
mm-hmm so who was your advisor who were
the mentors in in this period of your
life uh most greens the physics and
technology it's very interesting
approach it's a so-called physics system
yeah what does it mean it means at first
three years you work in classes and then
you go to actual national labs and you
choose them they choose us etc and three
years you work there and you listen to
the classes but these classes they are
not from teachers not from teaching
professors but from very very high level
actual scientists so and who was so who
was the the person who was the person
that you connected with who was your
advisors in that fourth year fifth year
yeah well and what's coach Atif so
that's one of that's that's the
connection yeah yeah cool chatter it's
that's downtown Moscow right oh yeah
yeah cool shot of its the guy is like a
father of Russian atomic bomb and he
build a bigger actor in central Moscow
the interest and all that it was in
nineteen in 1919 1946 I think you know
they do the first rector and then the
bump and 1949 so and it was a it's it's
you know like in America there is a
group of national labs different like
Oak Ridge National Lab Los Alamos
National Lab Argonne National Lab
etcetera in Russia I would say most of
this lab they were combined together in
this one
Kolkata Institute of atomic energy so
it's like you can imagine like a
combination of most of American national
labs in one place it was fifteen
thousand people working there fifteen
thousands a huge it's like a sitting
inside of city and when they were
created they were focused on nuclear
physics and nuclear engineering and
everything around development to build
atomic bomb and the same thing for
[Music]
fusion bombs so for hydrogen bound and
but later they add solid phase physics
groups etc so yes it was a I would say
any still now the most I would say the
strongest research center and also with
you so I decided to go there and I
decided to go to plasma so in January in
1972 I came to they did not let me
inside of crucial minutes I came only to
the gate and I met my first professor
who brought me there it was professor
Liang he threw the coffe he is now
professor emeritus of University of
Maryland I saw him couple of years ago
was that and he brought me to his house
and he we spoke and just he said I just
remember forever he he told me you want
it's like a the story with winnie pooh
and
he said you wanna tea with milk or with
honey or and and my answer was exactly
the same as we needed poo I did not talk
we need opposed that time I say okay
all of the above please because why
because you're hungry very simple and he
spoke to me and he started working it
was and I made my first actually paper
you wrote your first paper that's who
you were and I was on plasma
it wasn't asthma and but then in the
half of a year he told me that he likes
what we are doing but he will be unable
to help me in the life because I am
Jewish and to a Jewish person even like
absolutely brilliant to get inside of
course Chetta you have a stronger
helpers and he recommend me to meet
lagina rusinov
and very early glasses at that moment so
it was a moment when I start new names I
know well because of the song as this
legendary so because of you I seem to
have met a lot of people from fist yeah
yeah
and much like MIT they're never shy
about telling you that they're from fist
yeah there's a lot of pride so I notice
on the fall maybe you can tell about him
the other guy let me guess the gossip
when a lot of people these days know
from the show of Chernobyl who is but he
obviously has deep roots and coaches
often is a very interesting person so
okay so rusinov who's this legendary
human that I've heard so much about well
with you know that plasma fusion plasma
Elysian talked only like making it stock
market it is diagnostic such a
measurement characterization so the most
challenging is how to measure it so Rose
onif was world accepted as a father of
plasma diagnostics
so he was a very very very nice person
working with plasma diagnostics both
theory and experiments and at that time
in 1973 approximately oh he decided he
was asked by League Asif to start plasma
chemistry not plasma physics but plasma
chemistry because they wanted to
dissociate uranium hexafluoride and
plutonium hexafluoride and they were
unable to do it without like in
traditional ways and they decided write
plasma so and rusinov agreed to take a
lead in plasma chemistry and at that
point you see that I was in a good but
good moment you know in a good place so
I was lucky actually because all of them
they were physicists especially Roshan
of deeply deeply deeply physicists and
he needs help from a good young person
who is not afraid of chemistry being
physicist so he looked around and
rudakov told him that there is a young
guy very interesting personality he is a
good and physics but he's in laughs
chemistry also so try him and to me he
said go to row serif he's a tough guy
but but he will be able to help you
because to help you to stay to go
further in your life because his close
friend working together with Li Gosselin
ligase was associate director
vice-president of course Adam Institute
so that's how it's all started and they
asked me a couple of things can you do
this can you do that in chemistry so it
is just physicists and talking chemistry
so let me step up because I'd like to
step back in a little bit to talk about
of what is plasma even so but before all
that let's talk about ourselves so what
let's step away from science what impact
did he have on you as a human being what
memories do you have of him that you
love or hate or both you know I would
say the best word would be both because
do you remember Ross on of hard to know
what I remember because I just told me
story personality he's the personality
he's he's extremely tough very quiet he
is mostly not talking he's only looking
at you always in your eyes he's like
well that's his brilliant smart he was
absolutely smart absolutely brilliant so
you can have very tough and tough and so
you have to basically makes for a great
adviser because this is a person to be
afraid of
yeah and you have to put you basically
for the rest of your life are trying to
prove yourself to him yes that's exactly
the case with a condition lady met
rusinov
yeah that's the personality yeah is
there a memory a story that stands out
to you maybe
that represents him well without going
to science right without I remember one
story just forever one of the I was
already not a postdoc well graded
student so it was one under grade a
student you remember from third grade
and muskiness physical ecology and she
was supposed to start you know after
vacations she came but but something
happened and she came about one week
later so it's her advisor which is
another famous scientist and I was in an
office of Mazzara so he brought this
girl and it's a nice girl I had not so
many girls in EM IPT Investec not so
many girls so she came to this office
and rusinov
he just look at her like a snake you
know like
look at her without any words for about
maybe the one in 30 seconds just look at
her eyes and then she said he said your
colleagues they start working on the
wiki though your what your colleagues
well other student yeah other students
they are already working start working
one week ago that's all he said and kept
looking at her just staring and staring
right and she you know like his ears
started going from her face yeah and it
was like a torture its he did injured by
silence and staring yes yeah that's a
good like a three three minutes but even
for me it was like maybe one hour for
her maybe it's like whole life okay
let's go to the most important question
how did you meet mom whoo
so this is before coach shot off I
suppose around that nine it's no it is
already i met mom in 1973 this is second
third fourth year of yours
well this was my third year no it was my
fourth year actually already and for mom
it was a second one she was there yeah I
told you that it's like three percent so
she was one of the girls on it being one
of the special few in this special and
yeah and she survived this kind of fall
so super training divided first year she
survived everything yeah I mean so how
did how did you okay so there you are
part of the 97% yeah
with a giant ego as we can already tell
by the way does your ego serve you well
we'll talk about a little yeah more if
you like yes I think yes what about so
in science yes I think people will hear
that you have a bit of an ego but I
think it's the
into your it's the same with five
minutes the same with I just Leonard
Susskind
a lot of physicists have this weird
dance with ego it's a useful weapon when
you wield a cautiously but did it help
you in terms of with mom I would not say
so about confidence
well how did you the most difficult yeah
is you know to to go to this because
it's a boy so and and girls they live
separately in different like this place
these are alligators and like what I
mean after you have to be clever and how
to get to this like a place I mean yeah
ah so what happened that on their floor
something disappeared I don't know some
money or whatever or some books or
something and and a friend of mine he
was you know like I would say dreaming
he we used to say so he was like a
student responsible for like everything
should be nice so I said that I will
help you let's go to these girls and
let's try to to help them so we come em
start helping and spend then the whole
night reading poetry just reading poetry
I think with tea that's it
reading poetry with tea was you and who
else
me mom and to my friends and it was also
two other girls which leaves the same so
do you remember what poems you're really
is there something if you can imagine if
we are talking about eight hours or
whatever in seven hours so it was a lot
of for three but is it
there's there something from that period
that stands out to you maybe as poetry
that you were reading not something
you've written for mom yet but do you
remember from that night I mean it's an
important night right yeah oh they
remember what kind of tea the cheap one
because this song is stuff we used to
handle vodka so no no so ok tea and it's
like a it was offensive for girls we had
a huge respect to that and then
gentlemen don't drink vodka in fair
enough so at least in the beginning so
when did you first fall in love with mom
yeah you know when you have like you
said it's 97 percent so jay-z important
it's immediately one two three yes okay
so but she she was beautiful and she's
beautiful and it was December 14th and
still even now we celebrate this big
summer for teens when you met yeah
well that's this poetry stuff but is it
was the same day was to wait December 14
two days ago
so we celebrated 46 years what is today
this is you met of this day was tea and
poetry but like it there also guitar I
think yes and when you say guitar I mean
there's a bar tradition as basically
poetry to music yeah any kind of lyrics
is really important yeah I would say it
was 96 percent it was mostly lyrics and
guitar it was just like
how did you win her over oh that's
that's that what's your secret
what how'd you do it uh actually also I
became her mentor which made my life a
little bit easier and you know I started
with poetry and I end up with science
and then actually and we stay together
we married three years after that do you
remember any poems you've written her
well I'm not no not of course you never
say it when I would for 30 years but at
that moment I would say like reciting
all this life poems it's probably not
the best stuff to do now it should be a
special discussion about that probably
together with her okay what I can say
that I have a couple of this book
booklets on poetry but it is already not
the same I was already not the same it
was in in high school which means at the
time already
most of my poetry was I would say not
funny but more like yeah woody playful
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay when did you
know you will marry her when did you
know that you know sort of this is this
is gonna be it's the one you remember
this one two three yeah maybe not during
first five minutes but maybe after 20
minutes yeah I'm gonna marry that one
yeah it is very I mean she she she she
is beautiful and she was even shocked
she was younger
me too so just almost immediately but it
was clear that we cannot do
you know immediately so we're waiting
until I graduate from from from from
I'm not on the gorilla from master level
because you know in Soviet Union it was
undergraduate class master it was like
higher education and after that it was
PhD levels just we wait until I'm done
the semester when did you first learn
that you will be a father some four
people don't know I have an older
brother uglier fatter stupider blood and
Greg oh he's good
just uglier now he's doing 1977 it's no
he was born in 1978 so it was not an
easy moment for me I would say even very
difficult moment because it was a
concept in Soviet Union which is
difficult to to understand here the so
called for a pisco it's just even not
possible to translate which means that
you have to have a special absolutely
complicated permission and normally
complicated mission to live in Moscow
and Leningrad which is in some
Petersburg now so to do that you have to
either have to be born there and that's
it actually so it was a close series so
and I was from Kiev and mom
she was a she is from Malaysia so just
how to do that in 1976 1977 I was like
the first grade of PhD first year of PhD
and without this permission to live in
Moscow so just it was a difficult moment
this is a practical thing because you
want to you want to stay in Moscow
longer term long because yeah because in
Soviet Union Moscow it was like a number
one place but mostly easy times this
permission that's extremely complicated
and because mom is originally from a
different area of the Soviet Union yeah
and there's called as complications
bureaucracy all that kind of she was
born she lived in the area for first
uranium the most important uranium mines
in Soviet Union so that's she's from
wearisome so what and that's where you
were he was perfect yeah yeah nuclear
that explains so much so how did it feel
like when one greg was born means just
becoming a father what was that story
like so yes it's a pain I was very much
well obviously I was very happy but I
was nervous about future because future
was not clear at that time not clear at
all about this time my situation was
actually very sophisticated
well it's a little bit long story but
what happened that I get sick and and
they did not know where to put me it was
infectious and and finally I end up in
the house of Sahara which is interesting
moment and was mixed all together with
Greg births with me being sick with with
the sire of all together whatever it was
like a vista mess it's just just a
stressful mess yeah and when I came to
get onto this scoffs to the city and
middle Asia in near now they call it
urgent
oh so it is near her gentle well I was
very happy and one of the first hour at
that point I wrote my first not book but
chapter in the book and the walls the
topic plasma chemistry
plasma chemistry and topic of my chapter
it was synthesis of nitrogen oxide from
air and there is a very famous I love it
the picture of Greg on the wall when he
just you know a couple of weeks and he's
read in the book and he's in front and
he's just like so much interest and he's
reading this plasma chemistry book yeah
it's a good picture
it's a good picture right so how did it
feel like so obviously Greg is a
disappointment
so how did it feel like when I was
finally born oh this you it was a it was
way of course way easier and we were way
more happier because it was 1983 so
which means that we were already in
Moscow we got this practice can we got
this permission and we got
and our apartment so just everything was
so nice and so beautiful and and you
know cherry on top of this cake it was
you and and the only funny story which
is like always mom she used to say is
like for some reason I don't know even
why but everybody were sure that you are
a girl and not you but like that is the
girl the girl yeah and so everything was
prepared for a girl and and we were
staying and near this clinic and me and
Greg and just and it was now that it is
a boy and Greg he mentioned his famous
friend that he's so much happy that
you're a boy and you know the story also
that he was five years old and he was
for some reason sure that to that man
they make poison and women they make
girls and he was so much surprising he
said that man she's so good it was
impressed yes that she could make a boy
a boy yeah yeah so that were you ready
to be a father would you say it you know
being father it's a big commitment
big big big commitment because now it's
a real family when Greg was born it was
like oh my was a mess so it was
very challenging it was very difficult
when you were like a fun and nice and
everybody they're so happy and even if
you look at pictures you know like a
picture with you that just yes the
following is the smiling it's a happy
bring joy to the world
yes and basically that's the way you
were when they were like you were always
you know you wake up you smile that's
good it's a good sign very good well
let's go let's go
so I I wanted to be a psychiatrist
selling me psychoanalyze you
do you think you were a good dad who
well to be honest it's not for me to
judge what I am but I can tell you that
my whole life
I just tried sometimes more successful
sometimes less successful to be good dad
that it's not for me to judge
I mean you know I can give an example
like when Greg was very young for me
like a very important was on Dow books
and I had these 10 books often Dow by
the way there are now there but here
they're in my office
and you know that's the books which I
read and just I put my yeah sweat blood
and sweat and blood and tears right into
this book and what Greg did he just took
these books and he took like a this
flowmaster what is that like Oh markers
markers markers and he everything around
is like a the cover of this he drew on
it no he just
it's like graffiti it's like it's all
over this and it was how to say you know
for me it was not a good night is sacred
I mean yeah and I was just I remember
this moment I was so much not happy just
you know and I just try to explain and I
mean and I ain't even and Greg he keeps
saying even now that that he won't he he
was sure that he is doing something good
that he's just you know that I love
these books so he tried to make them
even you know
prettier prettier yeah
that's so what I'm trying to say that
welcome to being a dad right there yes
yes yes
so if you can go back and do something
different in terms of being a dad what
would you is there something you regret
well you know I would say people they're
different
some people they always say they want a
different life and they sure for some
reason that if they start again it would
be better it is not my case for some
reason I don't know maybe this is just
like internal friends just to put like
you mention about Fineman but I just
always try to protect myself and family
and just I was sure like my father
during the war that if I am strong
everything will be good but and as a
result believe me or not
and it's psychologically it helped me
psychologically significantly I really
believe that I am always right which is
which is strange maybe yeah but it is
the way to protect myself I don't know
protect family so when you ask me what
you would be differently nothing my
feeling always is that my son is the
best one I always try to give it right
sometimes more than necessary and
probably it's I'm doing that wrong but
but I can not do differently I am I'm
sure that I'm right it's a kind of
defense mechanism so you fast like so
you don't you our family have done a lot
to make a better life or for us for me
and I think I've seen you work very hard
to take steps through life to do make a
better life for all of us with you Chris
many times
and there is a feeling that looks like
everything is okay okay okay so while
creating sort of creating taking risks
but creating opportunities for our
family for me for my brother there was
to me always I felt a distance so what
if I told you you felt distant to me as
a father and then I never really felt
close to you to this day do you think
that's true I don't know what I'm what I
can say that I tried as much as possible
to be as good father as they can it's
sometimes it's difficult to combine the
system with this self-protection like it
said um so that's you know so there's an
interesting it could be a Russian
immigrant thing it could be a Jewish
thing too but sort of say if you're
captain of a boat or something and you
see you have somebody precious your
family on the boat it seems that you
were more focused on just making sure
the boat doesn't crash or like sort of
focusing on or maybe getting a bigger
boat or the for the fail at like there's
this focus of the journey in providing
and stability and so on then then not
actually and not sitting down and
enjoying time on the boat that you've
built you know I have with with with a
family I agree with you but it is not
Russian it is not Russian it's the
Jewish and it's immigrants
because so many times I was very nervous
that one thing goes wrong and everything
crashes and there are the million things
in our life but I am always feeling this
point is the most dangerous dangerous
here that is okay that is okay that's
that's dangerous so I feel this danger
and I am overdoing this nervousness and
it is always with me and that's why even
now at any point I am too much nervous
because I see it looks like my feeling
is that like people they do not see that
this is a deadly point like a crucial
battle neck or whatever yeah and and and
I know that if I say that directly
people it can be not good so I have to
play with that in one way or another and
so but I would say that it's a typical
for Jewish people because they went
through hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds even a thousand years of
problems and also for immigrants because
that's immigrant life you remember your
own story was high school and the first
time came there I mean there is some
kind of tiny details which can make your
life miserable
yeah middle school I mean I was a
particularly interesting moment that I
think it's an interesting moment that I
don't know how to explore correctly
because we came to this country so I was
maybe 13 I don't even remember those
middle school and it was a very
different culture change it was a very
very very different culture and we went
to a it was a it's a middle school stuff
for people in general but I went from
having a lot of friends from culture
that I loved somehow deeply is sort of
this math and science and he talked
about this I mean there's so many French
dug deep friendships to a very shallow
place
and sort of the difference between what
you know everybody
I don't discount the suffering of people
but I would say I suffered you know you
you want to be like that's stupid but I
really psychologically suffered and at
the same time you were sort of totally
unable to understand that obviously
because well hold on a second I think
you came to America the the step to come
to America is a beautiful step of
opportunity so there's this the economy
of like to me that was a horrible thing
for my own selfish personal little
experience I didn't see that I didn't
you know at that age you don't think
about the big picture of things but it's
an interesting difference and the step
to America is it a really interesting
step because you're sacrificing so much
of who you are
it's a big big leap big leap but it's uh
it's the it's a good leap for the future
of the family for opportunity for for
building a life together and it's an
interesting how did you think about that
process we'll talk about it a little bit
it'll take a step back and talk about it
mores are big your family but as a dad
as a family not big but let's just
day-to-day how did you that move how did
you experience it how did you think
about it well this is a moment and I can
read for you a poetry unfortunately
again it's in Russian but I will use no
no it's okay I it's only a couple of
sentences I will give you from there
it's a beautiful very nice very Jewish
poet in 1941 beginning of the war
so he said catalyst Mirchi dude I used a
period eight emotional blockage with
summit rudeness yes by you just I should
Dania tacky well it's the Thunder fool
poem I can read the whole poem later not
with the microphone but listen to that
you are very nervous before but when it
is already attack when you are just
already in action you don't think about
that
so this moment of coming to America the
first period I was not nervous I was
like like a machine I was doing I was
doing that so yeah I mean it's the same
when you decide the decision is the
right one yeah you see I listen to a
three I can just you know it's easy to
translate it like when you are going to
attack you are singing yeah when you cry
it's before that you have the stress the
anxiety the tears but when you already
repair yeah you believe in your star and
you go and you don't think much
well let me pause on this as I asked you
if you think you were a good father what
what you know was I good son yes the
better one
then Greg obviously but no but what what
would you know without any hesitation I
can say that you were and you are very
good son because you understand when
you're talking and it was from the
beginning he always even if I never kid
you're not kids usually they think about
themselves and they see the whole world
is rotating around them but you were way
less serious for many years you just
used so people around you are able to to
see okay this is this is my version
thesis further I mean II you just see
people and that's incredible also just
from the like first months of your life
you're laughing smiling yeah and believe
me it is not so many kids are doing that
which means that somewhere deeply in
your I don't know where its genes
probably I don't know you were smiling
so you know like whenever I see it's a
good person or not so good person take a
look at the personal and this person
wakes up some people they wake up and
the immediate is smile ultimate that's
something I don't know it's like a
miracle so you are okay so thank you for
being a good son yeah maybe I'm not so
good father that's another story but
well the this context makes it much more
important for me to criticize you it
makes it impossible for you to criticize
me which is exactly how I set it up okay
but so you mentioned the gossip as one
of the people in your story
Kirchhoff Institute can you tell the
story and your involvement in Chernobyl
sort of that played a part in our lives
as well so what's the story there
what is Chernobyl okay for people who
don't know yeah Chernobyl it's a it's a
small city town with a huge nuclear
power plant um and it's a place of world
ever biggest nuclear severe accident the
reason of this accident the best if you
know Lex but other people they can watch
the movie which is HBO show yeah HBO
show very good actually
I did not expect but it is really very
good oh the major reason is they just
went through special tests and just
testing new regimes and they start to
decrease activity of reactor very fast
and the reactor starts dying and they
just increase activity and then they
were unable to stop it
and temperature go very high metal
clothing start reacting with cooling
water producing hydrogen hydrogen reacts
with oxygen and it was a huge hydrogen
explosion the so-called DDT and because
of this explosion actually a very very
very very heavy like a tip of the
reactor jump up low down and
forty tones or something like that I
froze huge just then destroy the whole
reactor and all this nuclear fuel start
falling down create some critical mass
and it was nuclear explosion but not
contained so yes it was what part of the
story did the show get right and what
part of story did you get wrong any of
you would be gossips just things you've
experienced a person so I just very
shortly described what happened yes that
like it was this kind of already nuclear
expansion and everything from inside was
boom went out and actually with the wind
make almost a half circle around the
world
so that's accident for instead of atomic
energy it was a very big deal because
the whole community the whole country
actually they consider that this huge
Institute is responsible for this
accident so the reaction don't forget
it's a communist country they decided
it's like like an army that all people
all scientists they are responsible dust
matter whatever if you do in plasma or
you're doing nuclear reactor does matter
you have to go and help you want it you
don't want it you like it you don't like
it in the movie it was shown but I would
say movie is about 97 percent absolutely
right absolutely
it's unbelievable how good they made
this nice they made this movie there
from the people the culture the science
every single interaction the bureaucracy
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they did not overdo that because it's
very easy to go like it's a communist
country that's why and vice-versa so
they did it the very good harmony is
very good balance yeah
that was perfect were they wrong here at
least my impression is that they show
the apartment of Lagasse's the gossip
was actually almost the copy of real
digas visually - yes yes yes yes as this
actor he looks like legal and just you
know Wow just like as a good actor
actually it's a good actor British you
know and that's but it was shown that's
like a little bit of already American
propaganda they show this leg Asif
living in like a small apartment like a
smoking cigarettes all right no come on
it was can you imagine like a vice
president of Academy of Sciences vice
president if he leaves an apartment
commercially in the Soviet Union where
that position means you get you get
handed given out the apartment he lead
no not an apartment it was like a
special house belonging to him it is
like a next door to the Institute it
this house did not belong to him yeah
but that's where he lived so just he
lived like an you know Castle and like
the movie it was what's your memory of
him have you know you know madam come on
he's my supervisor so like ok so it's
like a heavy it's like it like Marcia
for you yeah like I had like a serif and
like for you it was severe and like
lagarza for me it's like a motion cam so
did have chance to see more should come
yeah is he or laughing it's like the
other day every day
my feeling is he was very good in
nuclear chemistry he was he was a member
and very significant member of Communist
Party the difference was Roseanna
Roseanna was not very much liking
Communist Party
well the gossip he was so he was a
secretary of communist party
organization of crucial Institute for a
couple of years so this kind of
personality so he was a great scientist
very interesting very bright but at the
same time he was a communist and he kind
of believed in this communist ideas and
he took all that responsibility very
close to his heart and that's exactly
like it is shown in the movie especially
when the director of the Chernobyl
station made a incredibly strange
mistake because the wrecker was already
destroyed
you remember my explanation but what
they see the temperature is going up and
his decision was you know you're an
artificial intelligence not so much in
physics and chemistry but if temperature
is going up what people will do if they
are not professionals
let's put water there and he made the
decision to put an enormous amount of
water into the rector to cool it down
but people they took him come on I guess
we have seen couple of seconds ago there
is no reactor there is nothing to cool
down because it's now can we mention
this huge temperature and you put water
into this huge temperature and metals
metals immediately react with water
producing hydrogen so actually what they
did it's it's it's it's extremely bad
and it's nicely shown in the movie they
made the decision for three people to go
inside under director and open the valve
to let this hot water to let this water
out and these people they did it
obviously it was clear that they were
going today do you think the accident
could have been avoided the Chernobyl
accident you know it's so deeply
interlinked just Soviet culture they
know why no you know how to say is it
possible to be sure that it will be no
fire in the city um it is it's very low
probability it's a sexual incidence it's
a couple of stuff with extremely low
probability happened at the same time
but it was really important stuff
Chernobyl happened first of all because
it was no automatic system of control it
was impossible if they say already
accident there is no automatic system to
stop it oh why because it's a huge
reactor very heavy very very very heavy
in big way bigger than reactors which we
have here in the United States so this
is a more difficult to control so I
would say it was clear for many people
that sooner or later it will be this
accident and actually it is a copy of
accident which happened in America and
try my Island it's very similar but
American accident was more
better controlled so it was not so huge
l still see their excellent
well the gossip he took the stuff very
close to his heart
and and it is very nicely shown in the
movie and actually that's why he suicide
he took his own life here yeah and by
the way he tried twice first time not
successful a second one so there's a
there's a journey of suffering there
afterwards he he he took you know he
were the burden of credit for that the
responsibility and yes because actually
he was claiming that these reactors are
the safest in the world yeah and they
are but the they're way more resistive
to small accidents right but they have
this tiny chance of severe accident even
now a lot of these records are still the
same are still the same and still around
okay let's get into the fun can you tell
me what is plasma the simple explanation
would be like the plasma it is what we
have in fluorescent lamps if you look
around in your own it is something you
have in all kind of sources like a most
of monitors TV screens etc significant
number of them let's plays most plasma
plasma is ionized gas what does it mean
like we have gas around us and let's say
with electric field electrons are
separated from ions so yes you take
electron out of molecule so molecule
becomes positive ion and electron is
separate with an iron iron it's if you
take if take an atom or molecule and
take one electron out
would stay there so iron it is like a
atom or molecule after the saraburi
when they lost an electron and what's
interesting about anion okay very second
probably going to apply electric field
whoever is lighter take energy
immediately energized very fast so I ins
they stay regularly usually they stay
cold because they are heavy they are not
very much moving so they are stay cold
while electrons are energized almost
immediately yeah and their temperature
in most of plasmas whatever you do
electron temperature is usually on
ballpark it's about ten fifteen thousand
Kelvin or Celsius which means twenty
thirty thousand Fahrenheit hot so
electrons are very very very very very
hot and ions like gas they're usually in
most cases they're cold so if I take
like a cell phone and touch the screen
well inside you have where you often
have electrons with the temperature 20
30,000 Fahrenheit but you cannot feel it
why because it's a one electron per
million of molecules it's not so many of
them it's like let's say Syria
Philadelphia do we have billionaires in
the city of Philadelphia maybe 100 but
it's but it's not so much easy to meet
them on the street because it's only one
or two for a huge city so the same story
here so plasma it is very energized
electrons and usually relatively cold
gas but these electrons they can do a
lot like these billionaires in
Philadelphia few have like a couple of
these billionaires they can do a lot
it's only two of them but actually they
can influence life in the city more than
air itself
because they have abilities the same
story there so electrons depending on
gas they are able to create very active
species so they can be used as a source
of light like a fluorescent lamps and
they can be used to three different
materials so most of synthetic well I
would say 100% of synthetic materials
they are treated before coloring because
like you have a nice black tie but how
to make tag black if it is synthetic if
it is natural is solid real but if it is
synthetic material and if you try you
know paint synthetic material you know
pain does not stick to it
so you plasma treat it this electron
will activate the surface and colors
they start sticking to the surface what
is me to activate a surface so there's a
lot of plasma is interacting somehow of
the surface well this human skin yeah
some kind of surface so what does it
mean to treat a surface okay try it
station but it's you know if you have
polymer like in the case of your tie
if I would like a polymer what what this
electron does is just create or H and
this 4-h take hydrogen out of your tie
and this is a opening bond and usually
oxygen stick to there and become polar
so you cover the surface with the polar
groups which are always sticky so that's
what is going on you just take one atom
out you have free bound oxygen there
polar groups here stick you can paint if
if you put a droplet droplets of whiskey
on the suffer of glass it will stay like
a droplets but if you just plasma treat
this glass and then you put drop the
drop leg loops immediately cover very
significant area okay so let's let's
step back a little bit
so there's solid liquid gas he said yeah
it's ionized gas why is plasma sometimes
called the fourth state of matter so
what's the difference between gas and
ionized gas mm-hmm such that it's a
fundamental difference it is a
fundamental difference because like what
is going on that this ionized gas
immediately has very different behavior
the world plasma was actually created
just because of similarity with blood
plasma so like you asked the difference
between plasma and gas it is about the
same difference
like difference between water and blood
so species inside a blood they're very
much interacting with each other while
water they're not much interacting so
why here wing length mirror in 1930 436
he started using the word plasma versus
ionized gas because he said take a look
take a look take a look this species
they interact with each other and
another so there's there's echoes
connections to inspiration from blood
plasma yes and the degrees of the
interactivity more than that so the the
guy who just Nobel Prize laureate
earring lender was at first for analyzed
by the interaction plasma search on the
surface so you can say that he's like a
father of modern electronics hardware so
he come up with this world take a look
this plasma is kind of funny it looks
like a blood plasma and people they
start like using this phrase like a joke
then you know like it was really like it
stuck oh that's really interesting okay
so you said electrons really hot so
so traditionally plasma is supposed to
be very high-energy very hot
mm-hmm so he said train its electrons
but there's a hot plasma and cold plasma
so we'll 244 okay in hot plasma
everything is hot so if you have more
electrons and they are able to heat up
the whole gas it's a hot plasma like
solar plasma the Sun or Sun solar plasma
Sun uh
and in this case temperature is very
high fusion plasmas so just everything
is very hot in most of engineering
plasmas today including your cell phones
including fluorescent lamps etcetera
etcetera or in these case only electrons
are there huts and they are unable to
heat up everybody it's like this couple
of billionaires in the city of
middle-class people and but these
electrons there if it is air for example
they just electrons they react with
oxygen making atomic oxygen atomic
oxygen immediately produce ozone so
atomic oxygen sticks - OH - creating OHS
oh by the way
ozone means I think in Latin means smell
so the name of the guy who first saw
that it was Siemens if you remember
company Siemens so that's the creator of
this company because he was the first
one to understand this ozone and said
wow it smells
then he they use like a legend or third
word for that it was on and they start
using ozone for water cleaning right so
what's hot plasma and what's cold plasma
she said in the cold plasma the
electrons like the billionaire's is the
only thing that stays hot so what
hospital asthma everybody be on earth
and so in terms of applications in terms
of the theoretical physics under
underpinning what's the difference
between hot plasma and cold plasma
there's entire groups of researchers
that work on that yes yes you know the
fundamental difference is when
everything is 10,000 degrees what we can
do with this material with this plasma
it's like everything is ten thousand
like a ten thousand Kelvin like a twenty
thousand Fahrenheit what you can do I
mean that stuff melts everything and
convert everything into vapor when so
scientifically it's very easier because
it's like as close to thermodynamic
equilibrium so just very very very hot
substance one is hella many applications
applications the major application is if
you wanna melt something which require
temperature above yeah 2,000 Celsius
which is what the Isis torches so if you
want if you want a hot metal metal you
can actually you can cut metal with most
of metals they are just you know they
melt it on the level of below 2000 so
for these metals with some exceptions
but for these metals
fire you know combustion torches there
okay now if you want to melt something
which is impossible to melt like a
special hard ceramics
if you cannot melt it with anything
first of all why do you need it why do
you need melt something which is
impossible to Makaha if you let's say if
you want to protect your airplane your
airplane it's a good idea to cover
airplane with a thin layer of a
substance which is impossible to to melt
which is not afraid of anything not
afraid of lightning not afraid of
anything how to do that you have to melt
we have to cover it with this material
but to cover we have to melt it now how
to melt something which is impossible to
weld
well you have to take plasma so plasma
goes hot flash thermal plasma goes to
this huge temperature then you put this
powder you melt it and you spray
what's thermal plasma that's the heart
kind of that's a high temperature plasma
okay so what's cold plasma then and what
kind of temperatures are we talking
about what's this world in terms of
applications and theory thence now
fundamentally different from the heart a
kind cold plasma it is even it's it's
situation when you have electrons only
electrons are hot and they generate a
lot of active species radicals atoms so
they can treat different materials they
can make very sophisticated structures
but temperature is low so you do not
damage so let's say jumping for special
intelligence if you are talking about
computer how to make computer how to
make this wafers how to make these chips
yeah you have to be able to dig tiny
tiny tiny tiny tiny ditches how to do
that you have to have you cannot use
mechanical devices so you have to have
something different beams lasers no
because laser is heating its temperature
but you cannot take if you just use
laser you go to temperature eternal
thousand degrees you will damage
phone cannot withstand this temperature
yes the same computer so that's why
there is no alternative today only cold
plasma to make I would say vast majority
of electronics devices so hardware it's
almost you say hardware it is that so
let me beautifully put
what's now you said application we'll
talk about some applications including
plasma medicine but from a if we if you
put on your theoretical physicist or
chemist like fundamental science higher
what are the interesting problems in
plasma mysteries they're not yet
understood or things that have been
recently understood I've seen you talk
about incredible applications but let's
step let's not cover that first is there
some open problems
how was it understood from a theoretical
perspective I can give you a couple of
examples it's a lot of mysteries a lot
why because it is strongly non
equilibrium medium almost every cells
which we have around us it's an
equilibrium what what does I mean what
does it mean for a medium to be an
equilibrium equilibrium means it has
temperature has temperature yeah some
temperature like this is let say room
temperature well no I mean what you mean
by that is there's a uniformity to it
uniformity in temperature not space
uniformity but homogeneity like it's
near if temperature now can you imagine
something which has a couple of
different temperatures at the same point
as it possible yeah that's what it is so
electrons are very hot but they are
inside of gas and gas is cold like like
people they are swimming in the ocean so
temperature of a person is higher but
here just temperatures way way way here
now what starts happening in this case
it's a lot of
finding miracles a lot of funny miracles
for example electron impact creates
excitation of molecules to molecule a
stylus oscillate and people will learn
that distribution this becomes very
strange energy rich molecules they they
take more energy when they have already
something and okay rich people they
become richer and poor people then
becomes more poor exactly the same thing
they call it capitalism in molecular
life happens in plasma so what is going
on
you take molecules in plasma excite and
very fast against all the rules of
whatever nature couple of molecules they
have to quantum and they have more and
more and more and more than normal and
very soon make some molecules they have
everything and most of molecules have
nothing as a result if you have this
kind of non equilibrium immediately
creates lasers so this is one of the
reason why lasers first offers lasers
they were created in plasma even now the
most energetic like co2 laser except
plasma lasers and there's also plasma
laser plasma it's very accelerated
application but physics is here I can
explain it's a little bit longer how it
works but it's very similar to what is
going on with people if you already have
money it's easier for you to attract new
money if you are actually poor sooner or
later you will lose your money in the
favour of rich people not sure how well
the analogy works but probably but
they're saying that there's some
fascinating complicated instability
about that hole but it's interesting
it's interesting instability its
instability not space instability its
energy instability here
it's like a yes you said capitalism
capitalism at the molecular level
it's a capitalism it's a like a wild
capitalism yeah where just everything
works against the middle class who's the
Bernie Sanders in this physics analogy
I'm just kidding that's a who's the
social oh okay and I don't know let's
not take this analogy that's interesting
that you know that plasma works works
against Bernie Sanders so nature nature
yeah nature's as a is a more Republican
it's a more of a public nature is
Republican well no not nature at in
plasma Nanakuli it's only non
equilibrium class non-equilibrium plasma
equilibrium plasma it's everything it's
very much Bernie Sanders it's very much
harness distribution
yeah well non equilibrium plasmas let's
live a short life and die quickly so yes
so if you want a long peaceful existence
you want to go that's one of the reasons
why will these Bernie Sanders in visit
that's very interesting that but for
this reason non-equilibrium plasma cold
plasma is able to produce way more
miracles as miracles meaning very
interesting strange errand rapturous
patterns treatment like you cannot use
hot plasma to make electronic device
well you can do it it's just one example
another example is like a recently I
came yesterday well yeah yesterday from
Japan so we presented ionization of
liquids not gases so it's a lot of
interesting new stuff Oh liquids very
interesting yeah so you've mentioned
physics in chemistry what is plasma
physics what is plasma chemistry in
terms of application in terms of theory
what are the different lenses of physics
and chemistry that you used to explore
plasma and how do they differ you have
books on each yes
the simplest I think that it was fine
one who was asked what is physics and I
think it's him
and after some thinking he said well
that's what physicists do yeah so that's
a good point so actually it's a nice way
to say that's a stupid question but it
gives the question of more of a chance
so what's the difference between plasma
physics does McGuinness in even physics
and chemistry more broadly and can I
mean I don't know what's the more easier
distinction to draw yeah I can compare
with languages like what's the
difference between English language and
Chinese language in one case you have
how many I forgot 23 or whatever
characters how many well yeah it was
five okay something-something twenties
yeah and in Japanese Oh in the Chinese
you have ten thousand forty thousand
characters so Chinese it's chemistry
English it's physics physics has small
number of rules and laws of nature and
operates with that so understanding
let's say how to ionize gas it's physics
understanding how to create plasma in
liquid it's physics understanding how to
make a device how to make a light source
plasma light source it's physics now
when we are coming to Chinese I'll I
mean to this chemistry it means that
there is a million different tables not
rules tables yes it's tables instead of
rules and so what's not going on you
just look at that and see oh my gosh
this glass my special another
equilibrium plasma creates thousands of
species and we have to understand what
kind of species and sometimes you need
these species but you don't need these
species so how to have more of that and
I would have less of these
there is no rules well there are some
rules but about as much as in create
creating Chinese characters so a lot of
it is a lot of the knowledge in plasma
chemistry is discovered through
experimentation yeah and I would say
chemistry is more art physics is a
little bit more science like linguistics
you know English language it's possible
that's also a lot of challenges but it's
simple well talking about simple and
complicated going from physics to
chemistry let's go to biology one of the
exciting feels that you're one of the
founders of his plasma medicine what is
plasma medicine ok cold plasma cold
plasma creates a lot of species
interesting species unexpected species
you remember this capitalism in
molecular life you can a little bit
change parameters and it can be wrong
look I start generating this strange
substance it's a twisted so plasma is
very sensitive the difference is like a
human body and asthma generates very
interesting active species actually to
be honest almost exactly the same so
professor David graves he keeps saying
that he was impressed and he looked you
know books of medical biology books and
he said like a species active species
inside of human body and in Copeland's
they're the same so plasma create is
very interesting stuff and it was clear
for people from the beginning like
already for more than hundred years that
if you put plasma in contact with human
body
you can treat some diseases you can do a
lot of stuff the problem was that if
plasma is energetic and you put this
energetic plasma in contact with human
body you kill the person so actually the
whole point the whole interesting point
of plasma medicine so plasma medicine
came from physicists actually where it
become possible to make uniform not
damaging very energetic plasmas example
at atmospheric pressure example we have
atmospheric pressure around atmosphere
and there is a lightning lightning is
hot and very energetic and very damaging
plasma sources plasma discharges like
lightning it's impossible to use to
treat human body you'll just throw a lot
of this fry fry do you kill the
competition yeah now what happened like
when 16 years ago
it was the first time when physicists to
learn how to make lightning not like
concentrated in a tiny channel to be
diffused and just around a big big big
big area like to make it something like
a aurora borealis from lightning and it
was actually in 1990s a lot of like
efforts it was a French approach they
just etc but finally we won because what
we it was like a out-of-the-box solution
to make extremely short electric paths
short especially or temporarily in time
time in time so let's say because we
have when we have lightning between
clouds and ground
it's like a continuous voltage but if we
apply this voltage between skies and
ground let's say couple of nanoseconds
there is no time to create the Lightning
Channel
just simply no time so what is going on
you start creating something like aurora
borealis so you have a glowing
everywhere because there is no time to
create a channel so you make this pulse
and then you stop yes and then you
repeat this pulse again then you stop
and you repeat this pulse again
so through this not a second passing it
impossible to create a uniform class and
if plasma is uniform it's not damaging
aurora borealis you will not kill
anybody with lightning you will so that
allows you not damaging to now start
allowing plasma to interact with the
human body somehow so treating tissues
for example yes why is that interesting
what yeah what kind of applications are
we talking about okay today the biggest
application is related to treatment of
chronic wounds like our source
especially diabetic ulcers also recently
treatment of cancers because our plasma
sources are permitted to be used during
surgeries so when like a surgeon is
making surgery he removes cancer but
some margins are not treated so they
start using this plasma just to remove
tissue bad tissue without damage because
it is instead of like a scalpel it's
like a jet small jet for wounds it's a
very effective generation of the
stimulation of angiogenesis so just
drawing all blood vessels
so that's I would say two most
successful applications today what
plasma related Nobel Prizes do you think
will be given in the next 50 years so if
you look at at the big ideas in plasma
what do you think is there to be
discovered understood or may have
already been understood and and will be
recognized for it okay
closer to our field at least where we
are playing and if we are fielders our I
would say cold plasma for magical
biological applications I would say if
there is a significant actually accepted
by FDA etc success and treatment of
cancer there is a big chance to get
Nobel Prize what discipline would you
get it will be medicine in medicine
that's fascinating
that's fascinating it is this another
example which I like a lot personally it
is this plasma ionization of liquids
without bubbles that's the chance so to
get Nobel Prize for that because its
first of all it's a fascinating physics
ionization of liquids are bubbles what's
the niche of the bubbles that form if
you take liquid and put like a two
electrodes in the liquid to ionize
liquids you need a huge electric field
at least that's what most people they
used to think because mean free path is
small so electrons they they have to be
accelerated to have this huge energy so
it's either electric field is huge
or there is enough distance just route
to accelerate now if you have liquid
that's no much place to to go so you
have to have about a thousand times
greater electric field or you have to
create some voids if you create voids
and send of liquor that's okay
now that's what people that you still
believe but maybe about five seven years
ago people they understood that even
when they have very high electric bill
but not a huge and they start having
ionization of liquid so just the same as
plasma in fluorescent lamps but you have
the same thing in liquid and first one's
very interesting physics is a longer
story to explain that's very interesting
physics but also that interest
application because you have possibility
to have cold plasma inside of liquid so
you can synthesize new materials you can
do something so that was the reason like
I came a couple of yesterday making this
presentation of these discharges and
creation of this in the initial creation
of polymeric nitrogen because people
they don't have nitrogen polymers today
and that's in cold plasma it was
synthesized so it is very interesting
from fundamental point of view of
synthetic chemistry but nobody were able
to make like this kind of change from
nitrogen right so that was created it's
very interesting now this material at
normal conditions is converted back to
regular nitrogen releasing huge energy
way more than any explosive materials so
okay so those are two interesting ideas
yeah close close to your heart what
about what about the Sun what about hot
thermal plasma do you think there's an
interesting open problems there that
will help us understand the universe or
something like that I don't think so
today there is no I think for for
thermal plasma there is very low chances
for Nobel Prize kind of results however
there is a so called fusion plasmas so
plasmas because the thermal plasma which
we discuss it's it's thermal engineering
plasmas it's
it's plasmas like melting welding these
kind of applications coatings and
surface of the Sun surface of the Sun
but if you go to higher temperatures you
have fuel nuclear fusion but if in
normal plasma thermal plasma temperature
is about ten thousand Kelvin ten
thousand for fusion you have to have 100
million so it's more Wow so inside the
Sun it's a deeply inside and the physics
there is interesting
physics is extremely interesting because
it's a lot of questions with stability
and this plasma this kind of temperature
you behave very different so it is it is
I would say super fluidic material so
it's just it's it's do you think there's
possible breakthroughs in terms of using
fusion as an energy source or somehow in
you know that kind of like a crazy ideas
were out there ideas but on this podcast
I talk to people about aliens and
traveling across the universal if you
want to travel across the universe
you're gonna have to write healing is
that my feeling is that like a fusion
plasma in its traditional way which was
started in my Sahara in 1953 almost no
chances well I mean they have it they
have it already but the system is so
complicated
this tokamaks this big eater become
tokamak is so complicated so difficult
that personally it's difficult for me to
believe that it will be like a real
energy generating plant so this is being
up to control fusion in order to
leverage if yeah hey just say try
already for how many years of oxygen
that's an interesting point that's what
I'm trying to say
let I am almost sure that at some point
hopefully soon it will be young I'm not
very much young but usually young
out-of-the-box thinking person who will
say guys take a look I did it
something like envision some Thai
confusion you know there's a lot of guys
and girls like that who are called crazy
who've been talking about cold fusion
for decades
yeah so you think you hope that there is
a breakthrough idea that my lease yes
hey I'm almost sure about that and I
can't explain you simple physics
if it's forty seconds thirty side it one
and take longer put okay don't try me
take a look take a look what is fusion
you take the etherium three two or the
state of the cerium you bring them
together and they fuse and you they
release energy that's it right the
problem is that this is iron this design
they're positively charged and we have
to bring them extremely close and energy
required for that is 10 10 100 million
degrees that's what they try to do now
now take a look why we have to bring
them so much close we can bring them a
little bit and it will be tunneling so
they will start tracking it require more
time yes but that's okay but to do that
you have to have three smaller sizes you
have to have dense matter maybe 30 40 50
times denser than what we have now how
to do that you have to replace electron
by something very similar to electron
but heavier ions if you do that
immediately substance becomes smaller
and you start having cold normal fusion
but like a production and reproduction
of this material it's kind of
complicated people there try what I'm
trying to say that somebody will come up
with an interesting out
the box solution that's what I believe
well you're right a lot of people
they're a little bit I would say not
professionally just think oh look I did
it but but between these people or
between serious scientists thinking out
of the box
Samson will happen tokamaks yes they
work but there's so much complicated
it's very difficult to keep 100 million
degrees for isn't a long time just very
difficult beautiful unless whatever will
do that Nobel Prize without any question
okay the way okay refill refill you soon
baby shoes never do it okay we talked
about coming to here's to you okay doing
good three hours in we talked about the
journey to America a little bit but
let's take a step back it seems like an
unlikely journey that has to do with a
bunch of different factors ideas hopes
and dreams and goals and plans why did
we move to America as a family can you
tell the story there narrowly and
broadly as our big family that's a lot
of details out of like a interesting
stuff which happened at the same time
together first of all I was already in
France most of time which made situation
easier to go to America but absolutely
significant role was played by captain's
family what is the Caplan's family yeah
it is our last name is Friedman yes
taking attention yeah what's good Kaplan
it's a it's the name of
four of your grand grandmother yours my
grandmother my great grandmother your
great-grandmother
so her name was Kelly rich and when her
family came in America they changed name
to Kaplan's and it was forbidden to
contact family during an early period
you need to reach outside the country
Soviet Union to which so there's this
big family well not that I'm not big but
now big Kaplan family they came to yes
yeah and my father he your grandfather
had this interesting picture and without
much hopes he wrote a letter without
speaking English and you saw this
everywhere it is said like a Jew
newspaper and the word Jew was G spot on
g g e-- w yeah newspapers Cincinnati lit
it America and we got to his destination
and that's like a miracle
yeah that the letter came to this
direction it's interesting because the
newspaper published the letter yeah
that's uh it's it's kind of America and
that yeah it's a it's a miracle
so that's started the miracle they gave
a catalyst that was a catalyst yeah it
was an action and just as a result you
know we met and just an it was a
catalyst for me to accept the position
already for friends position of a full
professor in University of Illinois and
Chicago and that's actually how we moved
to Chicago so did you ever think that
you would come to America honestly no
even with my good friends we were
usually talking and my plans when I
understand that it's better for a
scientist to go like outside of South
Soviet Union
Europe Daniel dos tres and my choice was
clearly friends and we usually say that
I spoke with Boris Potemkin that I
always say that I will go to France
I said well and I want to go to South
America
Oh but actually heaven all the way
opposites oh yes okay
I spoke way better French language yeah
and I started a new French taking French
that there was there was a there was an
alternate reality where we moved to
France and I'm French
yeah and you're French and chances for
death were very high fifty-fifty kind of
thing I mean I remember there being is
pretty certain that we're going to
France
yeah it was more than 50% yeah because
we have already I mean it was very very
high chance yeah you remember the
picture I show you over there with me or
with French people without been shooting
off ski few no remember I just forever
remember like I'll mention I have ski he
loves you he useful oh he's a lobbyist
yeah yeah and he plays very nice piano
yeah it's a very very nice people and
there's a different world of scientists
a different perhaps more pure in their
pursuit of science a more support for
the kind of labs and the spirit of the
scientific process it's uh America's
academic research system is a little bit
more capitalistic I guess an American
professor spends about 50 percent of
time looking for funding and they're a
little bit more independent meaning
their own little startup more it's very
difficult to do an institute and so on
speaking of which I don't know how I
forgot to mention but the Institute
you're you've headed the Drexel than I
am plasma Institute for a long time from
2002 from 2002 what was that journey
like of all the many brilliant people
that have worked there through the years
all the different ideas
having an institute in America is an
interesting thing in itself yes all the
other what's that journey been like wow
it was very exciting and very
challenging and I would say that I work
very hard but I would say I was very
much lucky that I was able to bring who
is me a nice group of people with Nestor
good Sal poor chef and more recently
ordinary chant and then he'll the bring
in a lot now and in others so it was a
lot of people and they were good and it
was a very nice feeling of how to say
camaraderie camaraderie yeah in a living
including Greg who made a huge
contribution to that Norma's so it is
like it's my brother yep and I've been
on the outside of that sort of looking
in so I know a lot of these people
they're good and either stick or they're
almost like a part of family I know
they're part of our story in America
really yeah I know the yeah and we have
a handsome and to remember of my time
plus miniseries yeah yeah yeah low head
don't be shy no no no fear no fear yeah
don't be shy go head NPI and P I'd you
write that yeah you know eighth grade
your poetry has been going down downhill
and me we talked about that a lot that
writing poetry English like she's much
more difficult it's it's a and hence why
it's not as popular it's it's not more
popular gifts through in music through
hip hop through rap that's the popular
kind of poetic writing is in America
basically in France it is very closer to
Russia the French language allows uh
yeah French language allows for at least
like
song oriented poetry what would you say
is the difference between the Soviet
Union in America that kind of maybe to
ask it another way what do you miss
about the Soviet Union about Russia
about Ukraine you see that while me and
other people which came in our
generation which came from Russia
Ukraine Soviet Union we just we were not
happy absolutely not happy with the
political system over there but I would
say without an exception we are all I
would say deeply in love with Russian
culture which is absolutely unique and
absolutely beautiful and my and my
feeling that while I like American
culture also but a rationalist way
closer to my heart and I think it's way
richer the same thing is approach to
science which in Russia was very let's
first of all I like it because I was
younger which is always nice to be young
but you know this kind of feeling of
science is more important than
everything else and being a professor it
is the most prestigious profession
that's kind of interesting culture but
but the political system was not good
and nice now it's also challenging but
what do you think about Putin
with my Boonton insurgent of Putin came
to power after we left yeah
to sound here mm exactly you remember
this moment when we were in Miami Beach
New Year's New Year it was exactly the
day when putting the came a president
because absolutely unexpectedly one day
before that it was like a New Year
greeting from a president at that time
Boris Yeltsin and he said
happy holidays Happy New Year guys and
you know what I decided to step down
oops
and just I wanna another person to lead
the country different transition periods
and then we have elections so that's day
so we talk and I in different ways also
love certain parts of Russia and there's
still a part of me even though it's I
didn't spend there more than 13 years or
whatever
but Putin represents modern Russia so
that's why I asked if it's you know
we're we're Americans now really but
what do you think about this man who's
caring who's defining the 21st century
Russia I would say there is a to phrases
to sayings which come into my mind you
see you gave me 10 seconds to think
which is important there is a saying the
end justifies the means you know who
said that it's a there is a book here
it's a it's a Machiavelli oh this is by
the way his sculpture well so the the
head yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I know but
straight
I said Machiavelli in the book prince he
said that the ends justifies dreams
another phrase it's another nice guy
maximilien robespierre he used to say
you cannot make an omelet without
breaking eggs
on a papaya they have them let the Sun
Casa deserve yeah that's a Robespierre
and these two phrases actually they
describe for me at least Putin you know
that his way of thinking is it was a
huge jerk catastrophe because think for
a second huge Soviet Union were Russians
they were everywhere
- people Russian Russian and in during a
short period of time boons it is a 15
independent countries
what the hell and and like significant I
don't know I would say almost half okay
a lesson help but very significant
number of Russians they become like his
people living in other countries not
very much friendly to Russia so he put
all his efforts to change it to to make
it easier and better that and this is
the ends which justifies means and he is
breaking a lot of eggs and he's making a
lot of not good steps but for the good
purpose now just what I keep thinking
that Russian Empire it is a not first
Empire to disappear now take a look what
happened to other empires French Empire
oh my gosh they had enormous lis
problems very similar to Putin and you
know who was there Putin it was the goal
because in late 1950s it was an enormous
war in Algeria and the whole group of
Maghreb countries and you know what
happened they just even stopped the
Republic and they create absolutely new
constitution and it was actually
absolute disaster in late 1950s early
1960s but they actually went out faster
than Russia
well why it's a different story now take
a look another huge the biggest empire
in the world it's a British they lost
their empire and huge number of British
people they just stay somewhere the same
thing like Soviet Union but interesting
enough they they they made it they made
like this other countries which get rid
of British Empire but they were still in
love with the Queen they become part of
this Commonwealth and it was relatively
smooth so British they did excellent job
French hmm like always you know yeah
yeah tariffs but Russia so far doing not
good so they are just they they try to
help they try to make this kind of but
they break a lot of eggs should I
interview Putin on his podcast piece is
a very interesting personality he's very
smart and try but sure but what you want
to talk about because power future of
Russia future of Russia and is great and
it's right no no no not not doing not in
those kinds of questions
but in the kind of omelet and eggs way
and
in the space of technology sort of
innovation of science of becoming a
superpower again which is where you have
to you know the space race he will like
this kind of discussion because what I
know about him by the way he supports
the platform Edison little asthma
medicine yes because when he defined
like a three or whatever four major
directions of development of science he
mentioned those are the three owners and
plasma medicine yeah okay interesting he
really thinks that the ends justifies
the means
so he is not afraid to make any kind of
decision but to make country stronger
and and he did actually he did a very
good job from the word review of
you know all other republics they were
saying that I have all our problems is
because of freshmen but what Russia can
say if all these problems because of
yeah he took responsibility but with
power authoritarians power can is very
useful but it can also cloud your
judgment you can slowly become a lesser
man that you could have otherwise been
without being checked so doing the
complicated instantaneous it's a
complicated interesting story so you can
compare him with maximilien robespierre
so without a microphone between us we
often talk about artificial intelligence
you have a lot of opinions like you said
you're always think you're right and
you're right you know yeah barely half
of the time no I'm right absolutely
always it was exceptional of cases yeah
when I'm wrong wrong which never happens
yes it hasn't been observed ok so let me
get your profound deep opinions about
artificial intelligence do you think
we'll ever build systems that are as
intelligent or more intelligent than
human beings in the same kind of way
that we think humans are intelligent you
know the most important is the last
remark which you made I strongly believe
in their official intelligence I believe
that it will be a lot of development in
the direction of like a human similarity
to human but I've very much doubt about
artificial consciousness this kind of
stuff from my point of view it's very
questionable so I don't know what is
consciousness to you consciousness it's
it's way more it's a wider stuff it's
like a wow it's complex of feelings
it's a complex of feelings like
intelligence its smartness it's a
knowledge it's a disability to operate
with knowledge consciousness it's its
knowledge but way much together with
feelings do you think science will ever
be able to understand consciousness so
here I believe I believe that sooner or
later at least in this direction will be
big breakthroughs so do you think do you
think could be able to put consciousness
inside a Roomba inside a phone inside a
camera devices consciousness
consciousness I don't know you know like
a Jewish answer to most of the questions
I mean we don't know yes we don't know I
mean I it's very difficult to predict
what will happen with science and 300
years it's like to ask 300 years ago in
what in 19 in 1700 come on it's way
before Napoleon
yeah the in every years of last year's
of Luke at all
whatever the Dalek for teens and you ask
them about cell phones what do what do
if you ask Li cateura if you ask him a
question what he thinks about cell
phones he will say this we call a I am a
Sun King uh-huh that's it
no you're simplifying because perhaps
the perhaps perhaps but because it is
another words cellphone but if I asked
know about artificial intelligence then
explained it correctly
he would actually have an opinion
already they've had opinions about these
kinds of things but yeah yeah sort of
can man this is a fundamental
philosophical question can human beings
create artificial versions of themselves
with Frankenstein other than me people
have been thinking when you bring out a
build of statues it's a and and people
have been maybe not Jews but people have
been confidently providing answers okay
what I can tell you my feeling yes
artificial person will be created okay
so the way it is yeah how close it will
be like a this like a synthetic
synthetic person will be with respect to
reality yeah is it good or bad it's just
different great but it is doable so we
have this disagreement a lot and you
think that so do you think such a system
needs to have a body and our
disagreement is often about the senses
you say to have a full reading
experience of consciousness you smell
touch so and I say you can do just words
words and the image not even just words
but yes image is helpful but words even
just the award's voice okay you know
like don't forget I lived many years in
France so for me smell like a Armagnac I
mean smell is very much often more
important than taste
yeah but image can be even less
important so just taste and smell so
what I'm trying to say that I mean but
that wait wait if I give you an option I
had to kill all your senses except one
which one would you like to stay with I
would not you know that's not it's like
a good question it's like a question you
know if you have a choice to kill your
father or mother what do you would do I
mean it's not the father
well yeah what I'm trying to say that
it's my feeling it's more holistic that
people they can lose one of feelings
it's okay
but yeah that's true and yes that's not
life but you think it's it's actually
it's a bouquet including like you said
cautiousness is a bouquet I like it but
you think a system should have a sense
of smell sense of touch and my feeling
is that it's not so difficult to do yes
from so this is where we have
disagreements and debates and software
or says hardware I mean you're much more
comfortable with hardware and and taste
and smell these are kinds of things that
it's it's almost like a sensor it's a
chemistry problem yeah but it with me
actually I am from harmony I'm not
saying this is hardware this software
yeah I would say that that's a it's not
the bouquet in this case it's it's a
harmony I mean yeah no I guess I come
from a world it's a very kind of AI
world in computer science world where
you think that most of the problems in
the world can be converted into a 99%
software problem and that's that's the
dream because it's easier than but but
do you know it was a Russian comedian
absolutely beautiful shiny etske maybe
you remember he might be nervous
he used to say in Russian the way it is
put it of Russia of streets is
hypocritical Tony which is nothing
probable what does it mean well how to
forget me translate it into English hmm
let's now don't even try it's fine Ehsan
it's fine but what I'm trying to say
that this this is a poet is is it
possible to describe with words tastes
of oysters if you never ever try them
and that's very important moment
sometimes this big data their official
intelligence they say ok we don't need
smell we can describe what has been
described as smell it means that they
can collect data about like a smell of
cheese and put it in like a huge
database and based on that to help you
to choose what is the best chase without
smelling so this in this case I have to
recommend to this computer or to this
computer scientists to think about the
netsuke
and this argument about taste of oysters
without trying them at least once in
their life ok that's why I think that
taste is important smell should be also
encoded yeah I disagree because I think
it is that so I agree that's very
important but I believe our mind and
artificial minds will be able to fill in
the gaps so without being able to smell
you you start without ever having tasted
or smelled oysters you start imagining
smell on taste it won't be connected to
reality at all but you construct a world
that's consistent so I would say in this
case it's not artificial intelligence
it's synthetic intelligence and I prefer
it official because in the world
artificial world art yeah you know what
I mean also and synthetic means like
yeah
you synthesize something yes no there's
no it's lacking of the human experience
and artificial has that art yes well you
you might you might be right because the
only intelligent system we have now has
smell oh really
ah okay very good I like it do you think
about mortality your own mortality yes
because there is a three elements to
that one like I'm a normal person and I
think about that Oh
especially in relation with parents when
you lost you know yes and mom also so
you know yes you cannot let something
which happened to everybody
at some point when you lose your father
and mother you understand that now it's
you you're next
that's into its well that's human
the second element what I think about is
religion because at least for me but for
many people also like going to beliefs
of your parents grandparents etc helps
helps and you start to understand the
older you are the closer you are to this
moment the more you just feel it so all
of the religion is huge and number three
I'm a scientist
and a couple of weeks ago we had a long
discussion on the conference
about immortality at the was of this
cosmetic meeting because I mentioned to
you that with this LVMH like a Louboutin
or whether um and Hennessy that's the
important one and then sporty one we
have been talking about like a
possibility to change direction of Aging
and this is one of challenges which
actually in the beam of plasma medicine
we start trying to do it was like a kind
of serious experiments trying to use in
plasma tool to determine aging process I
can explain you details but it's a
longer story but as a result of this
experiments
unfortunately we show that in a hundred
percent of like experiments we did we
actually accelerated aging not but maybe
we have two other ideas you might be
able to from a scientific perspective
there is there is so hurt because you
know that mortality it just glad or
major put it in us this mortality in
which way we're stem cells and they just
you know providing differentiation which
is like a renovation of us like when
there is a tiny small kid he changed his
no siren on each couple of days so just
it's it's always like a renovation of
the tissue yes death and birth doesn't
birth yeah it is not like I thought like
it knows is like growing no it's just as
each time I have a new one now when in
your age
like I wasn't buying it happen less
often maybe once and I don't know 5 10
years but for me
fortunately are functioning like I will
stay with this nose forever now so the
only thing we have to do actually is
just to and this self themselves are
still there we just but their efficiency
is for some not very much known reason
went down down down down down down so
what we have to do we have to actually
help this stem cells stimulate them just
to become again more active and if we do
that and plasma medicine tried then just
you know instead of getting older and
other will go back younger and younger
is it possible yes it's against rule of
nature
no so this is sword way to think about
that but that's a really challenge
interesting that it was discussion on
this subject with leave it on if science
does arrive at that breaker if you could
live forever would you would you like to
live forever I think yes I would try why
not you know let's well I'll give you a
reason not is it makes a life you know
the fact that stuff ends gives it some
deep meaning you know Jewish people
basically they are deeply deeply deeply
in love with life you know they say
Lehigh to life so Jewish people they
actually believe that God gave us life
to enjoy what will happen we'll have
another life or not or maybe it will be
like again we'll be young
is it possible the Jewish answer is
absolutely clear we don't know so but
enjoying life it's the law
absolute law so if you have possibility
to leave you have to go on with life as
a Jewish answer and I like it
are you afraid of death yes how you
remember when you asked me how long did
you take for me to fall in love with
with your mother 1 2 3 yeah yeah yeah
you answered that pretty quickly so what
do you think is the meaning of life
that's a difficult question you you
never like this the silly questions
go back to your eighth grade self and be
romantic for a second yeah what's the
meaning of life yeah meaning of our
existence here on this little planet
well I remember that I kept asking
myself this question when I was in
eighth grade it was one of the crucial
question for me Oh at that time by the
exactly the same time when I roll this
romantic stuff and at that time I
remember my answer I kept saying day by
day which means the meaning of life is
just to enjoy enjoy today's life and go
to tomorrow
survive the day enjoy the day and use
your French existentialists you're a
researcher and yes sir
it's but you know at that time I didn't
have any knowledge about exists sure
lists whatever Sartor yeah specialist
tartar but I was actually sure about
that if you ask me now I would say I was
right I I thought I thought that was a
natural extension of the axiom which is
I'm always right yes yes yes but you
know in each joke it's a 50% of joke if
you present not but after reading it was
a book limo words right what's in
English you say soccer sorry
limo words slower I think in this book
he just when I read that it's basically
absolutely bad book fleet
yes archers I prefer Camus and the other
French guy yeah I just decide that I am
I was not alone with this kind of ideas
yeah there's other French guys what do
you hope Greg and I accomplish in life
and next I'll ask you for advice and
after that we'll drink some vodka
recalculating I know I'm not calculating
I'm just trying to recall a very nice
poetry you know between I I love Russian
poetry and it's interesting that my
favorite Russian poet it's actually the
woman's it's a mini Nazi timer and she
wrote like a short poetry just L saying
that she said nationalist any
rationalist Paul navona assumes a brief
yet aside nobility post yes way mr.
Spacely well and it is in Russian but I
am I think that it's kind of deep and
kind of smart I wish I wish you to be
happy and I know that if I push you in
some direction Earl Greg
nothing happened I mean I okay I will be
always recommending they always push on
you and and don't forget I am always
pushing anyway but you know that and I
have to do that because I am a father so
I and I'm always pushing in conservative
direction because because I am a father
and I very much wish you to have your
son my grandson or granddaughter yeah I
almost guarantee you that will do the
same
he will not recommend your daughter to
take a risk and to go to Hollywood try
to be an actress she's supposed to do it
without without your permission
what and as and that's that's that's
beautiful who make our own way and there
you always have given me a brilliant
advice that I almost never follow and
usually disagree with so but that's the
way it should be
yeah that's the way of life well so what
speaking of which what advice do you
have for me for the next 10 20 years in
life sort of in any direction see I am
hesitating I'm thinking about I mean I
have two ideas and they're kind of very
much wasn't yeah so from one hand my
approach was the same as Sarah so just
from one hand I like the idea just to
live your life and to enjoy and to be
prepared for tomorrow which everything
will restart again it's from one hand
from another hand I remember myself in
elementary school he remember beginning
of our discussion about this stupid guys
these idiots with stones and I just had
an idea just to build a rocket to put
there so I wanted to do and I did it so
this is another idea when you all just
put your heart into something for a
longer time not for one day but you have
to find your own way just and my feeling
is it to you personally found it with
artificial intelligence and that's why
my feeling is that in your specific case
my advice will be just not to let them
this idiots with stones to succeed you
have to deliver and that's what I'd like
and that's what I made me dope with the
mercury in the rocket but build the
rocket it's your choice
yeah because that's a rocket which
you're building but what is important
that you'll do
well I think this is a good time to uh
to maybe toast our family oh they do
some we thought we'll do we'll probably
drink more vodka but we decided to be
responsible adults and just save the
vodka to the end it's always a question
how much vodka we have to drink in
Russian tradition usually we calculate
for adults like a one bottle per one
bottle per a person
take a look at is made in Soviet Union
and it's 1986 this is what girl of my
father because in 1986 in a year of
Chernobyl
he gave this bottle a friend of mine
because this friend of mine he went to
America and he just missed my friend he
just saved this basket for us to be able
to just whatever to think about no
seasoning of my friend oh he's Sasha but
we call him Shura Shura but that's the
same thing as your best friend your
lifelong friend yes it's like you're mad
mad mad matter any shoutout and first
you can chose the family but let me just
toast to the best dad I've ever had the
best that I could ever ask for our love
you did yeah
I love you let's go
listening to this conversation with my
dad and thank you to our sponsors the
Jordan Harbinger show a magic spoon
cereal go check out Jordans show on
Apple podcast Spotify and tell them I
sent you listen to the Kobe Bryant or
Neil deGrasse Tyson episodes first or
just binge listen to a bunch of them
like I did and buy all of the magic
spoon cereal click magic spoon comm
slash flex in the description and use
code Lex at checkout if you enjoy this
podcast subscribe on youtube review it
with five stars on a podcast supporter
on patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter and lex friedman and now let me
leave you with a request if they're
close people in your life we've never
sat down to really talk with and they're
still here with us talk to them
heart-to-heart podcasts are not they
won't always be here with us life is
short and most of it is a distraction
from what really matters family
friendship and love thank you for
listening and hope to see you next time
you